2
[Music]
hello hello it is off the rails November
8th it's a beautiful day thank you
everybody for being here
it is I banished and punished Ethan back
for another podcast today's episode is
sponsored by
the ordinary
games gamer sups and stamps.com we love
our sponsors thank you thank you so much
to them we love them lunchtime
oh here we go
we got the music playing
now what
Jamie Goot Gooch family
farms's opinion may not be the most fun
fun good fun good fun good fun good
Goods boots
I could say anti-semitic things and
Adidas can't drive
try
oh no hit him with the barrier bottle
[Music]
it's not very girthy
Jeffrey Thomas
wow we have to keep our country gay
people
[Music]
oh oh just a glimpse of Fouseytube just
a taste
but not the whole not the whole meal
yeah so anyway uh thank you guys thank
you guys that was a magical as always a
lot of fun powerful actually huge impact
you know what we were saying my hair
looks like a Tick-Tock [ __ ] boy like it
has fully transcended the center is
filled in somehow
that is so true and like
it actually looks like a real haircut
it's weird
but there it is oh not that time
you can see right through that
desperation yeah thank you thank you
how's everybody doing Dan how are you
feeling specifically because it's spicy
hot chip is coming for you it's Hot Chip
Wednesday it's Hot Chip Wednesday
everyone's gonna be so excited so great
I actually am I woke up this morning
excited did you really I was like this
is gonna be fun show I get to watch Dan
eat a spicy chip
and I mean I'm not the only one
everybody in the whole episode on Monday
was like yo spicy chips all they wanted
to see
we did a good job building it up though
the suspense is insane that's true
butthole burns
yeah thank you to our members by the way
um
you guys make the show possible and we
love you guys and all our members really
appreciate you guys just want to say
thank you
top of the show real fast tomorrow
is the beginning I think is it a 10 a.m
Sam do you know I think it's usually at
10 A.M oh wait the website's down okay
here it is
our annual Black Friday sale starts
tomorrow at 10 A.M
and this sale is going to be insane I'm
saying there's like 70 off on a ton of
[ __ ]
it's in gonna be insane
very nice the only thing that's not on
sale is the November collection and the
Elon Musk shirt
everything else is and then the month
before is 30 everything else is like 50
to 70 percent off so you're going to
want to check that out if you've never
been able to buy Teddy fresh Now's the
Time I'm telling you guys this is the
set the opportunity of a lifetime so
there it is teddyfresh.com tomorrow 10
a.m thank you thank you yeah this
shirt's actually from the November
collection oh you can't buy it because
the website's down
and it's not on sale but you can buy it
still tomorrow 10 a.m not on sale thank
you candy cat meow
okay they'll support your name thank you
for the five gifts did appreciate that
[Music]
yo why did you have to bring ninja into
it man
ninja broke my heart yesterday
and Philly D broke my heart all in one
[ __ ] day they literally chose Elon
Musk over me
like dude he's not gonna [ __ ] you he's
not gonna give you any money
look as you guys we watched Philly dude
stab me in the back like people uh but
ninja I did not expect Ninja
he had no reason and we were just we
were trying so hard to become homies
with Ninja
you know I was begging him to come on
the podcast he even said that he was
thinking about but then out of nowhere
out of nowhere he comes for me
excuse me
did this shake your guys's faith in
ninja Sam and Ian and all you got die
hards
no
no
I concur
you don't okay thanks Zach yes I side
with you Ethan this is too far as
uncalled for
oh yeah totally Zach used to be my hype
man and now you go against me every
chance you got okay I'll tell you why is
because I don't want to stop playing the
sound bites they're too good oh that's
that's what I'm defending here I side
with you yes completely but I don't want
to stop playing them I wasn't gonna
force you to play stop playing oh okay
then yeah I side with you I would I
would never I would never impede on your
creative arts back then I appreciate
that you know what I mean
well here it is um I guess shortly after
I got permanently banned here's what
Ninja had to say about it everybody like
people like trying to get banned when
they get banned they're oh dude I don't
know
I thought it was free speech it's like
you're sitting here
impersonating the owner of the account
of of the company
first of all bro you shouldn't be
talking [ __ ] when you're missing shots
like that you [ __ ] rookie [ __ ]
seriously like I thought you were a good
gamer and I'm I'm trying to listen to
you talking [ __ ] but all I can see is
just how bad you are this game
he shouldn't be hitting those shots
right love yeah he's been playing that
game for [ __ ] seven years at this
point and he's missing these shots calm
the [ __ ] up
hey you know what you you know what it's
no wonder he fell off
seriously bro I'm coming for him now
yeah I don't know if I can do that stuff
I've been holding my tongue on Nina a
little bit I don't know if I should say
it though unleash bro unleash Now's the
Time as far as I know and I've been
thinking about this for a while but you
know we've been trying to like mend our
relationship with him so I haven't
really said it but as far as I know he
hasn't apologized to Pokemon for that
whole loss right thing and all the other
things so like dude you're out here
acting Almighty but you haven't
apologized to pokemane what the [ __ ] bro
come on dude that's such a good point
love that you bring up because we're
like oh what did he do he didn't do
anything yeah you [ __ ] up bro you
stepped to our Queen Pokey yeah and you
still have not faced the Reckoning you
deserve for that and I'll tell you what
I'll tell you what furthermore it's
affecting your skill in the game
okay yeah he's clearly keeping something
inside of him and it's clearly ruining
his skills in the game here you know you
gotta let go bro you gotta mend the
fences not burn them down because how
you gonna be able to get [ __ ] shots like
that when you have so much hate and
resentment and black goo in your heart
anyway let's hear what he says I just
got so distracted by those horrible
shots
impersonating the owner of the account
of of the company
making
Jeffrey Epstein [ __ ] or what you know I
mean yeah so so that's how I know he's
talking about me right
and it's not funny like ah
I thought comedy was I thought comedy
was alive and well it's like you're not
it's not parody that's
what first my first question is why is
he so mad about it
I was like what
what did what happened bro
is he an Elon Musk simp or something
like what is this like passionate
defense he's so angry about it yeah I
mean look dude it is first of all I'm
not
people like him and I think even
Philadelphia to an extent are missing
the whole point of this or not and like
it's not Philly team unless more of the
conservosphere
they just make up their own narrative
about how like I'm crying about how I
didn't deserve to get banned I don't
[ __ ] care I knew I was gonna get
banned the joke was is that Elon Musk
and yeah ninja let me explain the joke
to you since you are the Arbiter and
keeper of all comedy
and I'm sorry I know my hair isn't dyed
blue so try to [ __ ] uh take this uh
just from a normal plebeian if you can
please I'm not the king of comedy like
you or the goddamn red hair bro at age
35.
how old is he
uh let me check hey put that boat down
what was that too old to be playing
fortnite he's 31. 31 bro
it's time to go natural ninja Sam
yeah I don't play fortnite okay sorry
what whoa Sam show Sam don't do that I
don't want to see that
get good you're reading get good by
Ninja okay you know what Sam
flip to a random page and read me a
passage and tell me how we getting good
with Ninja
okay
play a match have fun
you're working too and take a minute or
two to stretch you'll be glad you did
okay hold on let's slow down a little
bit that is actually fire advice I'm not
gonna lie
how much that book costs
that's a hardback Edition man
uh Dan actually gifted this to us
yesterday yeah uh it was a uh thrift
store find for uh oh I believe it was
seven dollars
yeah
seven is kind of expensive
knowledge of that caliber
I mean I would call that a steel what
did he say stretch that's fine yes make
sure you stretch first you'll be glad
you did
that's true I mean I've never I've never
been I never regretted stretching so
that's true actually what we wanted to
do is do a couple games record our
scores read the book and then try again
do a sign yeah exactly well maybe like a
control group and everything like a real
scientific experience I actually think
that's a great idea I love that by the
way here's an exchange between ninja and
Elon Musk so apparently he he's under
the assumption that elon's gonna [ __ ]
invite him over to Austin give him a
million dollars and give him a horse for
a [ __ ]
he's gonna get his ass buttercup
some buttercups human
that was the name of the horse right the
Tre the Buttercup uh yeah
the horse that won all the Kentucky
Derbies and [ __ ] maybe yeah
is it is it possible whatever I don't
need to read it
but he's so angry dude what's his
problem
I was trying to be cool bro
free speech I thought committee was
it took him and he was a diving world
that's the joke he's the one that
tweeted out comedy is back on Twitter
bro that's cringe
he was alive
well at least we have that sound by it I
thought it was free space
[Laughter]
bro I literally don't think Twitter has
anything to do with free speech like at
all that's kind of what the joke is bruh
damn
I'm so embarrassing actually just even
whatever bro
there's more what is this
Ninja
that was when Elon bought Twitter Elon
just bought Twitter for 4.5 million or
40 million five million without buying
that kid's bank and foreclosing his
house was a flex
Ninja's got a lot to learn from Elon oh
yeah ninja once threatened a kid
and it's not funny
yes it is funny
okay
thank you
that's why nobody watches your stream
anywhere how many views you get like 10
okay it's okay 8K bro that's not bad
he'll always have one
if ninja has no fan or what what's the
saying if he has no fans he has one fan
or I don't know
you know what I'm saying yep
thanks thanks for having me on with that
all right well speaking of which
actually two Zach and ab were first in
line to pay for that check mark So a
beasts and Zach both signed up quickly I
uh you guys are now paying eight [ __ ]
dollars a month for this
blue check mark right it's just a
constant it's a coincidence that it
happened the same time that's that's
legit no it's not you can click it it
literally says this person paid for this
check mark when you click it this is my
oops um
formal resignation from the show I've
gone Hollywood yeah
right now so
I have to report your account SEC
because you're impersonating a Lou
love actually says he got one too and
sent this yeah yeah love was love was
trying to we kind of figured out how to
do it on this phone that's not true okay
yeah so how does it feel to be verified
though I mean it looks legit when I saw
a b sent that picture I was like before
I remembered that you're now buying it I
was like yo that looks dope but
in the dock I included what it looks
like if you click on it oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yes the difference between an
actual verified person so
here if you click this it says this
account is verified because they
subscribe to Twitter blue
but that's not ours though
and then if you go that's below that
that's his if you go below that it shows
the podcast which is like and the
podcast says this account is verified
because it's notable in government news
entertainment or another designated
category that's that's what I got
nope no it's not no it is
a b said it's coincidence you know I
just clicked on it you're lying uh I'm
doing this I'm the research guy this for
research I don't know why Zach's doing
it but that's true that's a fair point
why are you doing it Zach I'm gone
Hollywood man
the last show baby yeah
um Twitter blue verified now I mean all
the things you could spend eight dollars
a month on this is kind of the most
insane one though I mean yeah it's
pretty invigorating it's almost the same
price as a ninja book from the Goodwill
so you could buy a Ninja Book every
month that was only seven true that's a
dollar cheaper dude true yeah valuable
advice yo issue podcast members is five
dollars and you get a lot for that
membership let me tell you you got BTS
every week you got an entire podcast now
with video by me and in that podcast you
even get double audio double the price
double the value
and that's five dollars a month
and you're supporting me not some
billionaire [ __ ] Duke yeah so what's
funny is I don't know if you guys saw
that he temporarily added for like five
hours
um
the official post where's that one here
uh if you go down to the uh Elon section
uh it will be under 1A here I got it
thank you yeah so he added it seriously
was like for five hours and they even
rolled it it was a little bit longer I
believe I saw somebody uh say it was 16
hours so less less than a day but
they're so incompetent it's such a mess
there so they added another check mark
double check
for uh you know official for people that
are actually verified yeah exactly what
are you saying
I'm saying that you're lying and that
you paid eight dollars to get your
stupid Bluetooth checks do not concern
themselves with opinions
get out of here Dan
fair enough he's there I mean they're
right they're right they're right I
recognize you know what my agent Steve
Rossi will call you later
yeah so it's like it's so stupid so they
added another check his whole thing was
let's democratize the blue check mark
let's level the field but they added
another check mark that does the same
thing as this check mark and this check
mark literally became meaningless
and then he realized how [ __ ] dumb it
was and erased it after 16 hours
why Twitter is insane Twitter's a rat
hole
and now I mean you can still click it
and you can tell the difference so this
whole notion of the blue check it's just
so Spears uh it 1C is where he um in a
uh reply to Friend of the show uh Mark
asked Brownlee
yeah love Mark ass
he's a good guy
yeah so Marca Marcus said now there's
two verified checks one that shows next
to your profile and replies and retweets
and everywhere else major Twitter blue
subscriber the other one official only
shows up for certain profiles on the
timeline update it's now gone
so that was a two hour difference
between those tweets and then Elon
responded to him I just killed it
yeah and we were talking about earlier
dance like enjoy it while it lasts and I
agree this is going to be like oh I feel
like it's gonna be a couple weeks and
then get rid of this a b was like we eat
like kings from yeah
I think they'll cancel the blue check
mark for plebs I don't know
bro huh I mean they're already collected
in Revenue they're gonna turn that
faucet off yeah it might be very
successful I know there's a bunch of
idiots
like me and Zach so who knows but we eat
like kings tonight yeah that's right
we're we're verified idiots you guys do
look legit verified like I think at
least for a little bit till more people
start getting it it's all about the
image baby it's kind of a vibe
it's all it's all part of the bigger
scheme what we're gonna do is now uh
apply to verification on Instagram and
show them that we're verified on Twitter
hopefully they haven't heard anything
about what's you know going on I will
tell I will say this Ian I do owe you
for Mr verified I will buy you a Twitter
verification uh check mark If you so
please if you so please
uh yeah sure or well at that cost you
give me another Ninja Book okay for
different rooms right well one one for
here to keep at the office and one for
back home do you want a Ninja book or do
you want to check uh we I I feel like I
got to do the check I got it yeah Ian
you'll be the only Twitter blue person
who has it paid for by someone else
you're not paying for it and you're
verified so win-win you didn't win Mr
Ninja Book you won Mr verified that's
true yeah that's right okay okay
unfortunately okay here here's what I'll
do for you Ian and this is a long time
coming I have owed you here's what I
want uh Dan you have a company credit
card I sure do oh you go ahead and sign
Ian's account up
for reoccurring payments eight dollars a
month
you are now wait recurring why not just
a one-off oh just one month well I mean
you didn't say for how long
I could do that's a good idea actually
why do I need to keep paying for this
[ __ ] Ian the thing the the crown does oh
ab's handed me glasses the crown doesn't
go away it's not a one month one season
really a month
um
next month anyways thank you for the
gifted Jake man oh no I think it listen
I owe him big time okay he is Mr
verified I'm not going to take that away
I'm going to do reoccurring eight
dollars a month blue check until you're
too embarrassed and want me to turn it
off and month welcome to the club you're
pushing it the official McDuck I've had
two pairs of these same glasses for
years for this moment think of the
gifted by Jake man even even should
allow people to gift it though that'd be
amazing oh we're giving him ideas now
dude there's enough I have another idea
I'm gonna drop you real quick okay allow
people to modify or like edit their
profile with callers and [ __ ] for money
that would sell a lot oh they
it allows you to have I think it does it
allows you to do that in the app icon
look different yeah you're allowed to do
that yeah you should allow people
they should allow people to play music
on their uh profiles as well and then
maybe like have like a top like let's
say like eight friends or something that
you could like have at the top of your
profile that'd be really cool Elon
should change his name to Tom that
sounds like a smooth yeah no that's a
good idea elon's weird I mean this is
like you should make every Twitter
account follow him right every Twitter
account follow him change his name to
Tom
uh listen to this Tesla cars when
they're asked what happened to the child
that walked in front of them I just
killed it
good one we'd love to see it
yeah Elon Musk is a giant piece of [ __ ]
actually and that shirt which uh you can
buy tomorrow because the website's down
it's up until Sunday
thank you thank you Elon Musk is a piece
of [ __ ] it's not on the website now so
it's kind of hard to promote it but
there it is it's up there
to you
yeah
keep it to you so you'll keep us
informed a B on how that check Mark's
working out for you yeah I'll keep it
for as long as you need just to see how
things go can I ask you do you have the
verified tab now I do and that is very
cool actually because I have like all
these verified people like responding to
my tweets and stuff who I had no idea
follow me yeah but now that I'm in the
club it is helpful okay that's that's
the best part about it well all those
verified people are probably just a
bunch of other people that got Twitter
blue my dude that's what I'm saying well
you know what
these ones are legit click one okay here
are you sure yeah yeah no I was I was
going through earlier
um but that is a great point then this
is probably gonna work for about a day
right yeah until everybody jumps on
right because who who cares about if
people with Twitter Bloom responded to
you right right so also apparently you
get spam power you float to the top so
you can you should start [ __ ] oh yeah
with people's replies
that's why I did it I mean you're not
around and someone has to watch you know
until you return hopefully all right
well there it is uh that's that so
congratulations to Abe and Zach for
being verified congratulations yes
yeah also an important news
the lottery was at 2.1 billion and one
[ __ ] won that [ __ ] in Pasadena
that's right that's like Altadena but
close enough dude that's like super
close to us yeah
did who bought tickets for that uh I
think cam just cam I did I think Zach
did too of course dude of course I was
going to but then I I missed my chance
how many tickets did you guys buy I just
bought one
yeah I mean you might that's all you
need yeah I was just gonna buy one too
but it was so close Zach you got to feel
like that was almost you huh oh Cam you
live even closer yeah I mean it almost
was me I got I got robbed dude yeah it's
[ __ ] up next time I'll get it there's
always next time always keep your camera
next time
it is actually super rare for just one
person to win that big of a jackpot
though yeah
he just became one of the richest people
in the world just straight up that's
just crazy
quick update yeah so I went to my
verified Tab and at first you see otk
which is actual verified responding to
me then the next person has nine
followers yeah
that verified tab is going to be super
useful I can tell Welcome to Hollywood
dude you made it baby hey Brian Singer
just invited you out to a party uh AB do
you accept
has sent everything through Steve Rossi
he'll he'll handle it
yes yes yes
um I gotta say my my perception of the
lottery is so skewed because when I
worked there all I would see that would
come in are winners
like you know because everyone was
coming in oh right they're big prizes
that's all I would see at a lottery so
my in my head I'm like that's gonna be
me so everybody wins yeah it's easy I
see all these new millionaires this I'm
gonna be new uh yeah also I just wanna
before we get into some main topics here
um Elon Ma
I just dropped a new video
actually and we've been in touch with
him we're trying to get him for the show
that's right we need to find a
um someone who speaks Mandarin that can
help translate for us because actually
this isn't schtick he does not speak
English right Zach he responded to me in
Mandarin yeah and you had to you had to
convert that correct yeah is he excited
what's the vibe check
um he said uh that he would love to come
on so awesome um the only thing he's
afraid of is his English is not good but
I told him and responded to him that we
will have someone help him with that
wait he's gonna call okay so but this is
fascinating because we're saying this is
a deep fate that's what I pointed out
Live May debunk
one way or another this will determine
if it's a defect whoa this is breaking
so we got to get him on ASAP Zach well
right I think the logistics of this are
very complicated because he's 16 hours
ahead I believe so we're trying to find
a good time that works for both all
right all right that's busy man he's
running a lot of companies and meanwhile
if if anyone watching is fluent in
English in Mandarin uh message one of
these guys on Discord and we'd
appreciate your help on the segment
in the meantime let's enjoy a new fire
from yilong Ma
um
give it to me
Neil
mother
[Music]
um
I love you very cool
ah yes my God he's the [ __ ] King he's
so cool
so much cooler than real Elon
I just I love so much that he he just
hits records on these videos with no
plan like he just seemingly has no idea
what he's gonna do in this video just
kind of winging it he gets it but he's
not in the car he's got the suit he's
got the hair planning yeah he just
didn't figure out what to say yet
so we love that so oh that's exciting
he's going to call in and basically
we've talked about all that but I think
what we really need to just get into at
this moment is bring out that
[ __ ] Hot Chip Dan uh no what we
need to get into is our ad and Ila just
walked in to do ordinary ads and then we
can do it with our sponsors and then
right after that we are doing awesome
hot chips
we got um milk and stuff for him Sam
yeah I guess I'll go start prepping that
yeah
that's a good idea Eli you want to come
join me
ela's joining me for the um ordinary
spot
Elon Ma
very cool
money give to you
um
yes yes everybody stay tuned it's
happening
Dan is eating the chip
thank you baby
all right so let's take them
um
thank you to our sponsor oh here let me
yeah maybe I won't wear that one yeah
maybe not
thank you thank you guys to the ordinary
wow
we absolutely love this brand I hope we
did one read before I hope you guys went
and checked it out
the ordinary is essentially disrupting
the market the beauty care Market
um we're talking about like face washes
ointments yes oils all the super
expensive kind of like designer Boutique
uh kind of things this is all stuff Ela
uses she has to bring this from home
brought this with me from home because
I'm actually using everything and it's
just such a beloved and such an iconic
company you getting this stuff for like
these are like between five and ten
bucks whereas if you go to unheard of a
designer brand is probably like like you
said a moisturizer that you got for me
it can be like
from 30 to 100 you know and then there's
like extra expensive which is just like
innocent that's the one with baby
foreskin in it not even but actually
there's that brand I know no but there's
no baby foreskin in an ordinary just
really high quality products and what's
so good about this
is that it's like as good or if not
better than the super expensive stuff oh
I I think it's actually better
personally that's why I use it I've I've
tried the expensive stuff
yeah it's really better the thing is
like I've always felt like the beauty
industry is such BS because I have the
markups are insane and it's like that
can't be true and they're really proving
that it is just exactly and it's really
hard to tell because you know people are
just kind of you're just kind of like in
a vulnerable position you're like I want
my my face skin you know I don't want
wrinkles I don't want to age that's true
I'm gonna do the best I can exactly
exactly so you were kind of willing well
maybe if I spend more you know maybe
it's better but I I really don't think
so yeah what's your favorite products
here this they have so many
um so like I was kind of saying last
time I really really love the cleanser
because I've had such a hard time
finding a good one because they all
really dry my skin and this one doesn't
it's Square Lane cleanser this one's
like 10 bucks I think for the big bottle
and then I also just love their
moisturizer
um because it just feels like clean and
good like I don't end up too oily or dry
natural moisturizing Factor plus h a
surface hydration formula and I think
this was like five or ten bucks it's
crazy and then I used the retinol tell
me about these oils I'm not sure so
retinol is like against its anti-aging
it's like a drop of oil and you rub it
in this one is not oil exactly but it's
like a why would you describe it like a
serum or something yes serum maybe yeah
you just yeah you use a drop like this
will last me forever yeah
and then they have the um neon cmide
Sam's got us on that the niancionamide
that that was actually the first product
I ever bought from them that's how I was
introduced to this brand the nianthamide
10 plus zinc one niacinamide nice
ceramide it's nice anyway guys here's
what's so cool for the whole month of
November they're doing their slovember
sale it's 23 off the entire website
except Black Friday they think that you
should take your time in shop and not go
into this you know Panic buying on Black
Friday so their stores actually not
selling stuff on Black Friday I guess to
uh to uh say hey slow down we got 23 off
the whole month slovember and guys go
ahead and follow the ordinary and
Destiny on Instagram and Tick Tock all
November long and learn one other thing
go ahead since we sponsored with them
because they also sent us product I
didn't know that they had hair care so I
tried their shampoo and conditioner and
I am not exaggerating this conditioner
feels like the best thing ever ever
it says and listen to this it says
benetrinium chloride two percent
conditioner like they are in the lab
figuring this [ __ ] out dude that's
awesome it made my hair feel so good
yeah so it's it really is such a great
company guys I mean this is my like this
is my natural hair and I used these
that's awesome guys when you feel ready
to shop check out theordinary.com for
the world famous science-based skincare
at 23 off savings no code necessary
and um all the ordinary Destiny websites
and stores will be closed on Black
Friday and run a 24-hour live special
called slovember TV where you can meet
their team see their in-house labs and
even get more expert advice don't forget
to live shop
live and Shop slowly the ordinary will
be waiting for you yes yes uh link is in
the description
it's the ordinary
um and links in the description yeah 23
off thank you guys so much thank you
Ordinary Love that and thank you either
for coming by nice to hear from you
we're passionate about this and also you
know what I'm passionate about yeah
Gamers oh let's go Gamers up Nation dude
I've been hitting this um yeah what are
you drinking the black cherry did you
try that one really good I love the
crawler no it actually matches my outfit
yeah I usually drink it but I didn't see
that it's purple I didn't know this
purple blue
gamer sub offers the healthiest and best
tasting alternative to energy drinks and
sodas Gigi helps you stay focused during
the day without feeling like crap it has
cat it even has caffeine free options
for people that don't want caffeine not
me I love this caffeine it gets me
charged up I feel so freaking good
I need to bring it with me to work like
what am I doing yeah no it's great like
I always say I used to get so drowsy on
the ride home and coffee and all this
stuff it doesn't help for somebody that
just doesn't help and you've seen it
it's horrible but gamer sub I drink this
during the show and I drive home so
alert and not tired is really amazing
enjoy getting an energy boost to your
day by simply throwing Two Scoops into
an ice-filled shaker cup or cold water
bottle and Shake It Up tastes great and
it's a healthy alternative than anything
with sugar in it it's probably cheaper
than any drink you're drinking currently
too A lot of people use this product as
a gateway to a healthier lifestyle
that's so true if you can cut sugar out
in any way Dr IDs taught us diet drinks
all the way man all the way
also you can use code H3 for a discount
at checkout new flavor guys we got titty
milk
from Jay schlatt guys exciting titty
milk ladies and gentlemen
so go oh can we do we get City milk in
yet I want to try that
I think there might be oh yeah next time
next time a good guy hit that titty milk
bro that titty milk yeah the only titty
milk I'll let you try it thank you thank
you but not your own
work on that
use code H3 to get you 10 off the whole
order the link in the description takes
you right to the website and auto
applies the discount I love gamer soap
I'm so grateful and I'm so happy that
they're sponsoring us thank you to them
you're kind of rocking this haircut too
that's what everyone's just sorry to
like make a complete uh side note here
[ __ ] boy tick tock haircut
[Music]
though
but then when you realize it's parted in
the middle there yeah no that's not that
good would you ever wear it if this was
filled in here no but buzzed here no no
no way no way no way yeah would never
happen could never happen
I have kids man I can't be watching this
haircut like that it's just something
there's something off about it uh we
have one more sponsor the true always
true the always great it's stamps.com
you know them you love them it's the
holiday season guys let's not get caught
up in the hustle and bustle of going to
the post office when you got
stamps.com to get you through stamps.com
has been around for 20 years serving
more than one million businesses uh get
access to USPS and UPS Services you need
to run your business right from your
computer there's no lines no traffics no
hassles you get such deep discounts
working with stamps.com you get up to 86
off of USPS and UPS shipping rates
because they do this whole massive bulk
because there's so many people using the
service that they get massive massive
discounts
uh the Dan's girlfriend uses this so
we've talked about it but how it works
is it's revolutionary they send you a
scale you weigh the package right on the
desk Nest to your computer you print the
perfect amount of postage you attach it
to the envelope or the package and they
come get it you can put it in your um
you know put your box your post box but
you could just put it on the porch and
they come get it I mean it's rev it's
cheaper and more convenient yeah
stamps.com bro
usestamps.com to print postage wherever
you do business all you need is a
computer and a printer
just like I said the holiday season
trade uh late nights for silent nights
they get started with stamps.com today
sign up with promo code H3
TV th3 because it says H3 here Dan I
know we had a whole conversation about
it and then I actually just sent you a
message to remind you yeah you said your
message was super confusing you said
okay it's stamps.com H3 not h3tv but it
says stamps.com H3 or it says code H3
let's move on sign up for the code uh
promo code H3 for special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a free digital skill there's
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com Click the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter the code H3 uh also yeah get four
week tryout free postage and digital
scale stamps.com H3 thank you stamps
thank you thank you thank you stamps.com
wow we love them what great sponsors
guys please support our sponsors uh they
they are just the best so there it is
um cool what how you doing Yola nice to
see you good busy at work look who just
got verified
McDuck McDuck oh dude
I paid for it
I had to I wanted to specify you I did
not yeah because it's been better wow
it'd be so humiliating to actual paper
yeah it was cornball [ __ ] yeah for sure
and how far have we come where you don't
even have a Twitter anymore and Ian is
verified I know wow the world is wow
something's wrong as they said in
Alexander Hamilton the world turned
upside down thank you can I Ethan can I
ask you because I linked a thing now
that it's verified official the tweet I
put in the dock yeah can you tell me if
you've ever done this because Sam and I
had a huge argument about this you guys
had a huge argument here let me see this
um
it says scientific when you were younger
did you ever get on the bathroom sink
and bend over so you could see your own
[ __ ] okay what and I took a picture
if you scroll down a little bit
just like this I'm sure I have yeah I'm
sure I did I'm sure I did you really at
least once in my life that was my answer
too yeah it's like I don't remember
specifically but sure I did yeah
probably but you're like what does a
butthole look like right and then and
then yeah I'm sure I just stand up on I
think how else are you gonna see it and
bendo what there are ways to yeah much
easier ways well maybe you're not smart
enough to think of that when you're
eight I mean I'm talking about like a
little kid this is the only mirror you
have access to there's not really an
easier way that is true this is the one
and only way to see a butthole the poll
said that uh it was like 34 yes so one
out of three people you walk by them
but I think they're lying I think more
people have done it than are leading war
or they just don't remember because
again I don't remember specifically
doing it but it's just I'm just ignoring
like yeah probably wait wait you don't
think you ever did that ELO it's just
specifically the fact that you guys said
you ever get on the bathroom sink and
bend over no I've never done that
yeah yeah you guys had a huge argument
about this huh Sam well Sam she's not
here but
um she she was like baffled that's the
thing and I took we had a chat with Zach
I texted Zach Zach and me was like it's
weird if you didn't do this I think it's
a guy thing I don't know yeah maybe a b
have you done it or not
I I may have gone more to the side more
than under just kind of like a right
like a Twist what you could see your
[ __ ] from the side well it depends on
how flexible you are I guess he's he's
that's essentially a yes he's just like
maybe taking issue with the mechanics a
little bit but ow ow
well there it is so congratulations on
the check mark I'm paying him back for
the Mr verified um yeah it's about time
oh great we all have uh our new Overlord
to thank here yeah
all right thank you Ian
so moving on oh Dan's gonna eat the
spicy chip you know you want to watch
this Connor I was supposed to have a
meeting now but we moved it to move it
cancel it
clear your books
yo um
this is happening by the way I have a
question before we get into this is the
Andrew Tate thing not working because
I feel like there's usually more people
watching and I wonder if people are just
over Andrew
let's do a poll let's do a poll what do
you think is better the poll is not
helpful at all why because these are the
people that are watching they need to
pull the people that aren't watching but
I bet you it's right okay how can we
pull the people that aren't Electronics
I'm not sure but my neck doesn't exist
you know doing the poll Andrew is
defending Andrew Tate seriously a good
click bait or or bad good or bad [ __ ]
yes [ __ ] yes
whoa there's a new there's something new
in here there's a q a
feature oh starting q a answer viewers
questions live
we'll have to check that out I don't
know what that is but there's a new
button anyways um is doing live it is a
good segment by the way Andrew Tate
uh good click bait was that the yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what
it might be yeah we don't have your
Twitter Twitter to promote the episode
no I don't think that makes a big
difference we can just put it on ours
baby
I mean too I genuinely don't think it
matters the Twitter [ __ ] although maybe
it does maybe I got [ __ ] maybe I [ __ ]
myself
but the the thing is the story is very
good the Andrew Tate one I actually do
think that strong lead for the nose okay
okay let's try this then Dan let's try
one more
add all three add defending Andrew Tate
Dan eats the Hot Chip Elon Musk is
ruining Twitter which is the best one to
lead with go Dan
[Music]
you vote for the best one which is the
best one to lead with go make it happen
Dan don't roll your eyes this is your
job
but now he's like talking about
islamophobia and getting all this and
defensive and you went woke you
literally converted two days ago and
this dude's like out there like Malcolm
X or some [ __ ]
it almost was ruining Twitter chat is
spamming titter I guess I said titter
you did nice shut up you did you you
shut up dude
all right this is
up I personally find this information
really useful because you just never
know dude okay Dan eats the Hot Chip
really
no of course
I feel like Dan's right it's not gonna
help yeah again we're polling the people
that are watching this is not this is
what last place is Andrew I think we got
to change I think we got to change the
titles around okay put defending Andrew
Tate at the back we are switching it all
up Dan eats the hottest chip in the
world
okay we're gonna we're gonna dress that
one up
so I'm if should I stay uh it's already
Absolutely I'll go run to the bathroom
now okay okay
Dan eats eats the Hot Chip it's already
too long yeah Danish the Hot Chip well
you could take out this seriously from
Andrew Tate
okay drop that
thank you guys this is uh this is
important I want to stop the show in its
tracks
oh my God I am rolling my eyes at that
just to be clear yeah thank you for
clarifying I appreciate that you didn't
eat the hottest chip in you say the
world
huh say Ian I said Dan oh uh it's too
long by one character what can I erase
just erase these no oh let's [ __ ] go
neuter me baby
I don't think this research is objective
enough you don't think this is a good uh
nope
you think they want to see Danny the
ship the most but I think more people
would click for the other stuff
I don't know actually they might be onto
something let's we'll keep an eye on the
views and see
and uh I don't know what to erase to I
think we just got to go back to eats the
Hot Chip instead of hotter no no no no
don't do it don't do it
delete delete
here we go how about Dan eats the
world's hottest chip love that there
that's for you happening it's all
Happening by clicking delete Lina are
you ready to re um
to re-challenge me because I want to I
want to fight you back for the title
yeah
can we get some extras chips we have to
have an event so we we tried to get more
what uh this morning and they were not
available in any of the stores that they
sell them in you were gonna have them
ready for me today yeah I would have
eaten it I would I know well let's have
we can make a special event of it me
versus Lina well so I eat this today
then no no it's a separated nice try
nice try dude
totally down for that yeah it'll be fun
we can set it up like a boxing match and
just see who can go the longest because
I think I can do it oh don't aren't I
supposed to like use gloves or something
so I don't [ __ ]
destroy my eyes
you're trying to beat my time I'm
definitely bound to go again because
how can you do it and then you know I
don't get another chance because after
you pass the six minutes is that how
long I went for yeah you went for it
yeah you beat me so no we'll do it at
the same time Lena oh okay we'll do it
together at the same time the winner
you know what I mean just duking it out
Joker brain style they've doubled the
price on Amazon and these things 20
bucks they're 18.50 now what the [ __ ] I
paid like
like seven or eight bucks and that was
insane already yeah 18.50 for one is
that by the distributor or is that like
a resale I buy the the what hockey store
Taki they know what they have the [ __ ]
went viral
wait I need to get my ass in the Hot
Chip business yeah for real twenty
dollars twenty dollars one odd chip but
we only need two more dude that's that's
hot
what's the price this time it's an
experience oh really you're shaking me
down Lena you wanna know what's the
prize I'm just wondering that's all
there is a prize we should make a bell
oh a belt money that gets passed around
we can make a trophy we can make a a
spicy chip trophy
that'd be cool because I'm defending my
title so you want a bell you want to
come in with the belt
uh what about a gift card to Sharky's
does that sound exciting yeah
I like the trophy idea
Sharkies then
100
again all right so Dan last time we did
this there was like a whole hoopla
everybody was I'll try to dodge the
draft no I'm not dodging anything
where's my gloves where's the milk
where's like all the accessories I'm not
being taken care of right now here on
this table yeah come here come sit yeah
you're right yeah yeah
let's do it like we did all the
everybody else either once you go sit in
the Scorpion chair yeah that'll be good
have fun all right so Dan is joining me
in the hot seat thank you a little play
on words there for you appreciate that
so Dan is finally at long last
ship in hand
oh yeah weeks in the middle oh yeah how
are you feeling Dan
uh you know I know it's gonna suck but
I I
I'm okay with spicy stuff I'm not I'm
not I'm not gonna build it up like oh no
big deal this is definitely gonna suck
but I'm not like super nervous and
what's the hottest thing you've eaten
before
well I've had the [ __ ] ultimate hot
Ones hot sauce when uh Sean Evans came
on the show and actually I took that
home and I used it a few times okay
because that I feel like that is really
doesn't compare to this just for the
record you think that the the pepper X
like hot sauce that they had is not as
spicy as this no not even close oh boy
well
uh I don't know you got a coconut uh
dessert bar how nice I guess that's just
a cool the mouth a little bit and we got
how do you milk an oat oh I recommend to
like I did to everybody else to take a
sip of Pepto Bismol before I did a few
minutes ago yeah
milking oat all right everybody's
excited this is this has been long time
coming we got gloves coming we're
bringing in the gloves bringing in the
gloves
check that packaging Ethan make sure
he's not uh tampered with that musical
[ __ ] weird Zach it just stays up the
whole time like oh
and we need some I got another [ __ ] this
is the intro okay okay yeah no it's it's
not been tampered with it's legit okay
okay now the way that I recommend uh is
to do it crunch it up so you can do it
at all at once so it doesn't touch the
side of your mouth you know what I mean
it doesn't touch your lips
that seems like cheating is that what
you did no we all did that
I don't know about that we all did I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it like uh
abuela in that one video where she was
just like just slowly eating it and like
well hold on before you big deal before
you do it do we have someone got a timer
on a stopwatch okay good okay so the
time to beat is six minutes which was
Lena's my I think I went for what four
minutes or three and a half minutes oh
right that's like how long until YouTube
whatever oh it's in the dock here let me
pull it up [ __ ] looks so gross it's
horrible like it tastes really bad
because it it has a bunch of dye to turn
your tongue blue gotcha yeah it's not
mold right no no I don't think anything
could grow on that bro that's a good
point here's a screenshot of all the
times we got just to refresh everybody's
I did 320. Lena of course is the rank
champ at 6 14. do you feel like you're
gonna be able to beat um Lena
no no
that was insane that was an insane Act
of endurance like I am still blown away
that she lasted though are you gonna try
to beat me in second place
I know this takes the fun out of it but
frankly I'm not trying to beat anybody
like I'll hold on as long as I can but
if it's if it's horrible I'm just gonna
drink the [ __ ] milk okay all right
all right we we appreciate it I don't
have the machismo yeah uh attitude about
this okay so uh without further Ado
listening oh there's like a little bit
yeah can you bring I don't want to get
the crumbs off the desk so like the dogs
don't eat it oh yeah yeah
that's a good point so you're not gonna
break it you're going all in
I definitely don't recommend abuela
style because it just lingers it smells
disgusting it The Taste is awful I'm not
gonna lie it's just [ __ ] putrid what
is that even
smell like
it doesn't smell like food well the
ingredients is quite simple I think it's
just like oil and spice it's just it
smells like one of the aisles at Home
Depot like it smells it smells like
Industrial
thank you baby all right so
um what I recommend is put let me grab
one of those yeah put it in your mouth
and then take off the glove and throw
the glove out yeah I'm just trying to
get that last chunk out here yeah and
grab that piece you throw that in here
bye-bye and that one too don't forget
that one of course
oh that one you're supposed to eat but
it's okay that was just some of the
powder
all right all right here we go we've
been waiting
this is exciting
the views are going up by the way people
are capable Andrew Tate's out Dan eats
the chip is in
all right good luck Dan we're here we're
all here for you buddy we're proud of
you too we're proud of you thank you
thank you go off King go off King
here he goes okay so he's executing a
traditional chip bite
it's all in his mouth you may want to
take off the glove Dan and then throw it
in here before you before the heat sets
in too much
good good excuse me I'll just clean the
desk off so Dan is um I see you've got
some chip residue on here just to wash
it down yeah yeah we did that because
it's so dry yeah that we did allow one
sip for washing it down scoot closer to
Ethan Den
yes come closer to me
so Dan is in the throes of Chip
he ate the whole thing I see you got
some residue on your lips your lips hurt
there you go
Dan has not said a word yet
the fire is rising
are you speechless that's hot that's hot
oh no Dan is speechless you can't say
anything nothing is on fire how did it
taste nothing it was disgusting it's
like awful yeah yeah yeah are your lips
burning
no no yeah yeah okay okay your eyes are
you're watering you're only gonna get
some watering eyes yeah
I'm gonna come out that butthole
talk to us I just no I need to go to my
location and is going to Zen Garden give
us how much how long has it been going
Ian
uh we're at a minute ten 110 not bad
you're already gonna beat Zach and his
ass [ __ ] like
hello
they're like green residue yeah it's
disgusting yeah it is it's very it's
very very gross and it's very like uh
mealy and it gets stuck in your teeth
and [ __ ] yeah
this is awful
yeah actually this is awful except for
the tears coming down your eyes you're
very well composed
oh my God he's doing great I gotta say
I'm very impressed so far Dan you're
just kind of
an alternate Realm
I do not like seeing Dan like this
I'm noticing how much I care for you
right now yeah I'm feeling really bad
really I'm having you yeah I'm super
amused by this I don't know what you
guys are talking about two minutes he's
fine he's killing it sitting there
crying
he's conquering this challenge he's
laughing he's gonna come up I want to
wipe my face but I'm still afraid of it
you should be good you had the glove on
you uh your hand should be clean okay
those is running too oh my God is it
getting worse or better no it's just bad
just [ __ ] yeah just a nice even [ __ ] and
how does this compare to the the hot
sauce the hot ones I mean it's been a
few years since I had that
I feel like the thing is is that one
kind of tasted good right right so at
least you had that going
this is just
you're doing great man what's it what's
the time at Ian we're at uh 250. 250
rounding the corner you're approaching
my time what was your time 3 20.
I mean
again it's not getting worse so like I
feel like I could just I probably you
need to beat Lena I don't know it's a
matter of want it's like yeah maybe if I
care it enough but
I'll beat you and then I'm gonna drink
oh okay okay but if you beat me that
means you have to compete in the no no
no no no no no no no no no no no you
know we don't have to do that you seem
totally fine I'm just gonna be straight
about at 3 20 which is Ethan's all right
wow keep pushing bro you can beat limo
Dan man up oh
dude you could take the title right now
you see him in the zone bro
we'll see okay you're pushing push yeah
yeah yeah yeah
oh here let me move just so we can see
your face a little bit I'd like to see
the face of uh the tears are streaming
man it's hot it's hot I mean what do we
expect
so is that the hottest thing you've
eaten would you say
I don't know how I could say no yeah
yeah it has to be yeah it is for me and
I did all I did like the thing is it's
on a different level because it's like
it's not food it's just uh four minutes
it is Dan your eyes look super blue in
contrast to you right thank you for you
to say yeah I mean it is like you said
it's like pepper spray it's like it's
not it's more like getting mace yeah
like eating something so
yeah I mean yeah and did this give you
more respect for abuela who ate this
yeah I mean I knew watching that video
that she was a queen yeah
Dan you're doing amazing you got this
thing do you want me to give you time
updates or you just want to push through
just
just let it be man okay
just let it be
so so God of War is pretty good right
pretty excited about that yeah yeah it
just came out yesterday last night we
were all playing I just kicked over the
spicy oh I feel like my my hands are
tingling man
my hands are tingling man it's not your
fault it's not your fault and now well
now that you've gone through it do you
think a b was overreacting no because I
mean he said he can't handle spicy at
all right and if that's the case I mean
this is miserable no AAP certainly
wasn't overreacting yeah that was the
first episode since I've worked here
between almost going to the hospital and
then making the flock of face after let
me ask you a question as well since then
was it against the world to spit because
that's like the main thing that's
[ __ ] me I don't think so here's my
trash bag
we're uh at about five and a half
minutes
oh my God W Dan that's your dad there's
just like a spicy syrup in my mouth dude
you're it's probably you're probably
just salivating you're a great guy it's
a self-d it's a self-defense mechanism
yeah dude you're getting close Lena you
[ __ ] up you threw the gauntlet and
Dan's about to take the Dub here I'm
proud of him I want him to do good thank
you thank you
[Applause]
I wish I was nice like Lena my hands are
tingling though like what does that mean
are you like a scary way
I don't know I don't know I don't know
if I should be scared Maybe
my hands are going numb
like uh
this [ __ ] song go ahead give the time
uh we're at about 6 15. you beat it
get it done all right you beat it
I'm gonna milk this out right stop it
and you can stop it get off the couch
wait you want to just you want to just
round it out to seven you're so close
what's he at
he is at uh just about six four maybe
don't drink anything
I'm eager for this right now mostly just
to wash out the face or wash out the
mouth how much longer are you in we do
okay you just gotta go uh let's see all
right ten nine eight no you start to
count soon five four three two one
wow a new champion
seven minutes on the clock Dan's word
love swerving Lena
taking the L today
why did you want to note that I mean I
stopped at six because
you know I could have gone longer but I
was already at that point and you guys
were like okay maybe that's enough right
just making it right yeah excuses
well you'll you will have your uh your
opportunity at Redemption there's
something on the line now Lena yes I
won't be happy to do it if you want to
beat me you go right ahead you're not
gonna compete no I mean maybe I'll feel
differently later but in this moment no
you have nothing to prove nothing to
prove this man right here is a champion
wow you feel proud of yourself yeah I
don't know I don't know I can't think
right now is it still smoke helping at
all or is that just yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you'll find I think in 10 minutes
you'll be totally fine that's how it was
for us right once you start drinking I
mean now that I've done it
like again that was spicy as [ __ ]
by no means am I gonna say it wasn't
spicy but my love of spicy food
definitely helped me here because it's
like I've been I haven't been here but
I've been close you know what I mean
training your whole life right yes yeah
I think you'll be fine you know when I
went home the the [ __ ] wasn't that
bad the stomach wasn't I just felt a
little it's really not that bad you're a
pro W Dan indeed well there it is Dan
ladies and gentlemen
the belt goes to you my friend
real top D is are you okay I don't know
honor oh whatever yeah I'm fine I'm fine
are you going to be are you [ __ ]
sucks yeah yeah true are you gonna be
returning to the Scorpion chair Dan are
you gonna need a moment I'll be
returning to some chair if you know what
I'm saying uh the toilet that's what I'm
saying you ready to [ __ ] already
another joke probably soon though let me
I'm gonna hit some more of this Pepto is
probably a good idea all right the Pepto
is is definitely a good idea Yeah the
more the better in my opinion
foreign
that was great I'm glad we did that you
know that was so worth it
uh so much hype around it okay let me
ask you this do you think Zach was being
dramatic yeah yeah
he's a little baby [ __ ] yeah because
Zach had like a crumb
I shouldn't yeah AV I shouldn't even be
mentioning you you [ __ ] ate that
whole thing with a beast thank you
I I mean yeah I even a crumb though in
Zach's defense I think it was hot
but it was a little funny when cam was
up there doing it insects like I think
my throat's closing yeah I'm dying I'm
dying
I actually in in Zach's defense
it does the the throat irritation is the
worst part I would say even worse than
the spicy in your mouth when my friend
Neil bent over this happened yeah all
right thank you Dan uh back to the
Scorpion chair thank you you did great I
mean really what a show y'all get rid of
my spit bucket yes please thank you
it's a coconut popsicle
and then that was an unexpected showing
I mean this just shook up the whole game
um
speechless frankly incredible damn
absolutely
they're stoked man they're calling you
wan W Dan yeah when
Hot Chip
don't let him talk to him yeah do you
want to compete we're going to do the
spicy hot chip world record for around
Christmas time
me and Lena what at the live show oh the
live show are you sure that's a good
idea that's a horrible yeah
everybody's like just silently watching
us suffer and [ __ ]
oh did you get lunch Sheila let me see
I'm hungry what'd you get make sure the
address on the bagalina
lunchtime
well I'm shocked man
that was so badass yeah
well I'm speechless
speechless
yeah well let's move on I mean how do we
even move on would you get a salad
it's um nah not really it's like healthy
bowl with oh interesting brains and
avocados damn that looks kind of good
rice avocado King a little bit
okay olives
yeah let's move on let's talk about the
election real fast I know we have
leftovers tomorrow but it's such fresh
news and I just want to say that I'm so
happy
we have good [ __ ]
um yeah
this morning like conservative meltdown
and there are some fire Clips I've
already found has Lauren bobert said
anything else uh unless it happened
during the show uh completely silent
from her that's incredible actually that
that I'm surprised she's not talking
about fraud and stuff already sure Ascot
beat down so it'll probably come but the
Frog talk has been minimal yes I've
noticed that they're more I think they
know they [ __ ] up
it's so nice it's actually so nice
yeah so midterms happened yesterday
um
everyone including myself was expecting
the Dems to just get wiped out a blowout
and not only did that not happen
the the races that I think a lot of
people really cared about for the most
part the Dems crushed
and actually what's even better is that
all the psycho Trump Mega election
fraudsters they all got dominated a lot
of them did I mean something like except
for like the MTG one again by like 70 or
something but that does restore some
hope yes it does it actually does it
really does yeah and I mean Lauren bober
I've we've talked about her on the show
before but she is one of the worst
people she is just a vile disgusting
woman and um the fact that she lost is
just it just makes me so
encouraged it makes me so
oh so good we should say
it's not 100 yet just the way bobert
she's stunned dude the account's still
happening and it's very close but it's
looking like it's done but wasn't it
unless there's been a call in the last
two hours Dan I'm impressed you're still
functioning yeah you're doing too Dan
you're normal yeah you are the man dude
do you want another popsicle
I kind of want another one just because
these are really [ __ ] good
bro you never had these before I don't
usually like coconut stuff too and this
is oh coconut popsicles are by far the
best I'm into it w Dan bro yeah
uh here well here's from two hours ago
Lauren bober is trailing
coming down to the wire last I heard oh
this is so good look at this
um
here's Lauren at her party she was
pulling ahead everyone thought she was
she crushed right
she's super popular she's like one of
the faces of the new Republican party
right man yep and there's her husband
who uh whipped his dick out to a bunch
of teenagers at a bowling alley and he
showed his dick to minors
very cool okay yeah he's actually sick
he's probably is he on the sex offender
list probably I should be yeah he has to
be so that's cool
by the way
the memes are already coming down every
time I see
destroyed Dan
yeah so here she is they're loving it
they're winning and here they are
um I think they're brands
[Music]
the the mood has gone down unfortunately
and they're asking God for please God
please God
let the people in line to vote be struck
him down let them die God
Lord Jesus
I send up my prayer to strike down the
Democrats
[Music]
let them develop Parkinson's right
before they fill that bubble Lord
[Music]
amen
so this is just honestly and even though
uh they still took the house by a narrow
margin honestly they're supposed to blow
out like 25 seats and they are now we're
only going to gain like four
I thought some there's still a scenario
where they only wind up with one one
it's so great I mean this is one of the
best showings of an incumbent president
ever I've heard
because usually the incumbent gets
annihilated in the midterms I kind of
felt like I mean I was hoping for
something like this because of
everything that's happened like
abortions yeah
I mean that just like upset all the
women yeah in the country as far as I'm
concerned I don't know about the
pro-abortion but you know that's a lot
of people
so I I was kind of hoping for something
like this but I really felt like there
was no hope yeah
I was so I was honestly so nihilistic
about this or fatalistic I was just like
I was like I don't even want to watch
anything yesterday I felt like I didn't
even want to watch anything about the
elections I was just kind of scared well
and the polls were getting worse and
worse the closer we got
and it was looking like the Republicans
would take the House and Senate
and now they're barely gonna take the
house and the damn it looks like are
gonna not only keep the Senate but
potentially even pick up a seat which is
just nuts it's just nuts
here but yeah I mean
I'm just so encouraged by this and I
want to basically
thank everybody watching because it
seems like the the young people the
Millennials that are the Generation Z
was they came out they actually came out
and that's old [ __ ] always win these
elections is because young people have
never been mobilized and they actually
went out and voted so I want to thank
everybody who watching the show and
that's why I think it's so important
what like what Hassan does for example I
think it's so important he's one of the
biggest twist streamers and he's
popularizing leftist politics and in a
landscape all you see is like Crowder
and Ben Shapiro and all these [ __ ] wads
and so to me even the leftovers
probably generates people that
absolutely hate me want to kill me oh
yeah
and all that it's so worth it because
I see stuff like this and I'm not I'm
not going to say that leftovers had an
effect or anything but I think that just
mainstreaming leftist politics to the
young people like on YouTube is such a
dub and I love that you guys all went
out and voted it's just so encouraging
so great keep doing it we're getting
those old [ __ ] out good luck with all
of that leftovers well in my opinion not
you know
no because you don't want to like you
said it's not just because of leftovers
or even just a sun
but what both Hassan and you do is I
think gives a voice to politics coming
from you know more left perspective that
isn't so um
that isn't so for lack of a better term
uh
preachy and annoying like you guys you
guys are uh you guys are funny and you
and you funny and you're a little and
you especially Ethan or your humor can
be edgy and um
and transgressive and you know just
showing that you know it doesn't have to
all be whiny
scolding you know there's a there's a
positive spin that can be put on it
um to make it fun and engaging and and
entertaining at the same time without
coming off is just preachy and nobody's
[ __ ] listening to Nancy Pelosi when
she says that's what I'm saying nobody
cares I think for a long time
justifiably or not the perception has
been that you know left uh politics is
uh kind of cringe and annoying yeah even
you know even if you agree with it and
um actually and it's been so easy for
the conservatives to just make
caricatures like insane caricatures of
the left right we could put in Kitty
boxes in schools and that we're trying
to uh we're trying to cut off uh the
genitals of children and all it's just
Insanity right
and I've seen people say that uh it
encouraged them to vote and that just I
think that that makes me feel like so
nice and so good and uh just so
encouraged that the future isn't all
doom and gloom and we're not all doomed
to just being [ __ ] over by a bunch of
Psychopathic Christian nationalist
fascists yeah and that's great love it
you know I think the young people those
culture warship just doesn't work on
them like the trans scare that they turn
into like the whole talking point of
their campaign it's about like trans
people somehow and the young people they
don't [ __ ] care about that they know
trans people they know gay people
they're not they don't buy that [ __ ]
they know what the [ __ ] is actually
going on yeah all the old pieces of [ __ ]
that watch Fox News who are like 10
months away from dying and then it's
like you gotta [ __ ] up the world 10
months before your ass dies and is in
the ground not everyone's young and
healthy you know the real irony too is
all the people that we constantly dunk
on like the daily wire folks and Matt
Walsh and everything they're the ones
that have been leading the charge on
trying to make the election about all
this culture War stuff and I think the
reality is and
I even they're already crying about it
we'll watch some clips of it on uh
leftovers but they're blaming the GOP
establishment you know the more
traditional Republicans for [ __ ] them
over in this election because of uh you
know they're not they're not mag enough
they're not uh
fiery enough with what they're saying
and if only they had listened to them
and frankly I think it's quite the
opposite the the reason the GOP had so
much momentum right now is because of
just basic ass [ __ ] like inflation like
yeah that's way better messaging like
the trans stuff
like you said I mean the reality is
trans people are extremely rare most
people don't know anybody who's trans
and and never and very likely never will
um and
you know making the election about that
I think was a strategic error on the
whole Maga Q side of the Republican
party because it's just that people
aren't that passionate about it and you
know what Dan it's nice to see you
you're actually crying now I've been
seeing the comments all emotional about
it right now yeah it's really sweet yeah
yeah no I'm just I'm real I'm real
worked up
he even complimented you
yeah yeah but you did yeah he did he
said that you you're funny you talk
about politics and funny you think I'm
funny then
it's not funny I'm kidding you're not
funny somebody said trans people aren't
that rare listen they are less than one
percent less than one percent of people
identify as trans that's that's all I
mean I understand there's plenty of
trans people but my point is just making
that the centerpiece of your election
was a strategic error on their part
because
it's just not it's not that relevant to
a lot of just average Americans no
you're right as a percentage of the
population it's a very small percentage
of the population not saying they don't
exist you know he's trying to for sure
don't take it the wrong way
but yeah
also some other good stuff like um
California
and a couple other states uh legalized
uh women's right to choose in the State
Constitution which we love to see
enshrined it
um
there's a Dr Oz got walloped [ __ ] Dr Oz
that [ __ ] ass quack [ __ ] go
back to selling supplements and Slot
buckets you loser [ __ ] why the [ __ ] did
you think you could be the beat the
fetty WAP why did he try to vote to run
for he was a republican bat Trump backed
he was running for Senate in Senate uh
Pennsylvania and it got walloped by the
big fat
show ELO a picture I have a picture of
him in there he's such a king
you're gonna love this guy dude dude
shows up in like gym shorts bro
yes you gotta you gotta show he's a
shorts King
this is why Ethan loves him so much in
shorts he's copping Ethan's style look
at this oh it's my boy right here
dude he's a union
it's so powerful
yeah get [ __ ] Dr Oz
[ __ ] Dr Oz bro that guy's a loser and
he's a little [ __ ] too he's like you
want to talk about soy boys or whatever
the [ __ ] that means he's like a little
[ __ ] weasel ass [ __ ]
hate him
now here's a unit
that man's wearing shorts and there's
snow on the ground you want to talk
about masculinity that's masculinity
that's your kind of stand up my kind of
man right there he is kind of giving
that uh relatable he is giving this he's
giving Gru a little bit yeah I like that
if he was in shorts that's a Vibe that's
a Vibe for sure loved that yeah so Dr Oz
lost
Lauren bobert lost unfortunately
um
uh what's your name the governor for
Georgia who I was really hoping
Oh Stacy Abrams yeah she got she got
walloped unfortunately but can't win
them all so so did beta Beto
unfortunately uh just didn't incumbent
same in Texas yeah Brian Kemp
Beto got uh beat by Greg Abbott
he is talking about the
there's this one guy that was like
running
what's his name Walker
oh that one's actually super close uh
Walker
uh what's the update on that yeah
Herschel Walker was another one we were
watching closely Herschel Walker is
basically suffering from traumatic brain
injury he's barely uh legible he can
barely speak he has very bad Motors he's
not exaggerating he was a former NFL
player and he it's kind of sad no like
if he wasn't heard about him yeah if he
wasn't advocating for horrible policies
I feel bad for Western but he's putting
them up too really terrible no he he
also he's running like pro-life like I'm
not calling Pro like Pro forced abortion
I hate when I call it pro-life he's
running on forced abortion or forced
pregnancy I mean and he and then it came
out that this guy's been getting
abortions his whole goddamn life with
women like he's just a giant hypocrite
he like beats he's the one that his son
talks yeah he's like European [ __ ] and I
hate you yeah yeah yeah so who is he
running against and is that you said
it's closed still yeah so he's
officially going to a runoff uh Ethan I
don't know if you saw that oh but the
good news is is that uh Warnock actually
was in the lead by almost a full percent
yep what's the policy in Georgia is it a
percent or two percent I think it's
I don't remember it's within one or two
percent let me check I think it's two
not five
somebody in the chat will probably know
in a second one catch the string catches
up yeah War if Warnock lost I feel like
that would be like kind of a perfect uh
outcome for us
or I mean yeah I mean if you won you
mean if Herschel Walker lost yeah yeah
I was reading something that oh it's if
If no candidate exceeds 50 God that's
what it is oh he's close man he's so
close thank you Kevin in the chat
yeah I read something interesting you
know Georgia there's a lot of religious
people a lot of uh evangelicals
this guy Warnock he's like a preacher
he's literally had his spent his whole
life and dedication of being a good
Christian this guy
88 of them voted for Herschel Walker
because he's like born again but it's
like he's just he's just [ __ ] bro
yeah
it's like [ __ ] them bro evangelicals
[ __ ] them that's all I can say about
that
he's not just a preacher by the way he's
the preacher at the church that Martin
Luther King was a preacher at
so he's got credentials yeah absolutely
like within that Community yeah I mean
that's a very prestigious church but if
he's up here it stands to reason he's
got a good chance in the runoff and I
think so and that that's encouraging too
so it was a great turnout and I'm just
super proud of you guys of your
Generation all the people out there dude
if you guys keep turning out in the
polls these [ __ ] don't have a
chance you know what I mean
so it's true also in La there was um
some interesting initiatives that passed
like a tax on like uh the millionaire
attacks they call it where houses over 5
million get like a fat property tax on
sales to go rip to you guys I voted yes
I did vote well good for you
um your class Trader but good for you
yeah you're the good kind of class
Trader I voted yes on all the tax
increase stuff there was a lot of them
in La I voted yes on all of them most
importantly we're firing the [ __ ]
gang leader Sheriff that we have here in
La which is [ __ ] sick that is great
[ __ ] I also saw there was an initiative
in La where they're like we can impeach
a sheriff now yeah like that was
impossible because of the same guy
that's awesome Villanueva is a [ __ ]
also the one piece of [ __ ] your brother
was telling us about how there's like
finally or was it you then there's
finally like a a CPA at the controller
oh yeah right the first CPA to ever be
the city controller I was like the
controller is the person in charge of
the finances so I was like how's that
possible but is a young guy he's
Progressive he seems very cool he says
he's going to audit the police and he's
going to audit yeah we'd love that about
you
[ __ ] the popo
yeah so there's all these real
interesting initiatives
it's kind of incredible to me the stuff
that people don't vote on like there was
another
rich people taxed on La that got
walloped which was um
oh it was like an additional state or
city tax on income over like two million
dollars a year okay that was going to be
used to I forget what it was going to be
used for but it got like overwhelmingly
shot down I was like who's voting for
this yeah like how many people in L.A
are making over two million dollars I
voted yes for it I think you know I
don't feel it's right for me to vote
against increasing taxes on me it's like
kind of [ __ ] up so I say yes on it
but it got shot down
what about um
Caruso
oh what's the update with Rick Caruso
it's too close to call it's very close I
last I saw he was slightly in the lead
really see that's that's that's a huge
disappointment
let's take a look there Rick Caruso of
course is like a Maga dude who just is
pretending to be a Democrat yeah and
he's running on basically like uh he's
basically building a giant ditch with
lava in the bottom and he's just
planning on putting the homeless in that
ditch that is his plan
I don't understand how much money is
being spent on the 100 million you spent
Rick Caruso has been 100 million of his
own [ __ ] money he's been getting so
many spam mail and letters and stuff
it's like every week there's like this
pile just because of the elections dude
we've been making a lot of money
probably on YouTube though because that
[ __ ] every time I open YouTube It's a ad
for the election I'm like okay let's go
getting paid out here yo he's dominating
he's up by elect significant
wait
only 43 of the vote in them and a lot of
people do mail-in voting I did we did
mail him exactly me too
okay that's interesting then that is
interesting long way to go yeah it's fit
we're not sure oh boy boy boy yeah so so
but the good news is yeah I think that
tax that they passed on
5 million it's like five million dollar
houses there's like a two percent
tax and over 10 there's like a four
percent tax and they project it's gonna
raise like a billion dollars a year in
the city and it's all going to housing
homeless people into affordable housing
which is kind of lots of [ __ ] awesome
and I'm so down for making our city
greater and uh more healthy and
beautiful so I'm voting yes on that and
that one did pass by actually a large
margin money so that's good that's funny
all of the uh good measures for dealing
with homelessness uh are passing and yet
Rick Caruso whose plan is just murder
them all
in the lead as well your disconnect
there yeah I think people are just so
desperate to but maybe the marketing
that he's doing too yeah I mean he spent
I think the most money million yeah like
absurd ability yeah and his endorsements
like Katy Perry endorsed him it's like
okay
every single celebrity you can think of
like they all endorse him wait there oh
Elon Musk endorsed him
everybody no there's a lot of uh people
who endorsed uh Karen bass but all the
like billionaire I don't know I haven't
seen any of them everyone it was
everyone
I see that Newsome Newsome dominated he
[ __ ] crushed which I'm happy about I
like Newsome
he destroyed that [ __ ]
I think it was a guy so I'm okay with
saying that
yeah but um
I guess it was a little bit closer than
I thought but yeah that's a huge blowout
6 57 yeah that's a lot of people 15
points
15 points yeah that's that's abomination
yeah so um so it's good but yeah I think
everyone's just so desperate to try to
make a dent in this homeless problem
that they're passing about the measures
and their
voting for the guy who says he's going
to do a change Karen bass is her
campaign is like I'm gonna do the same
thing that they were doing before which
I think people are like well yeah
frankly she's not a great candidate but
she's better than Rick so she got my
vote I guess
well maybe we can yeah I was seeing if
we could turn them into glue or
something to raise money for the city
that'd be a dub
put suicide pods around the city and
just collect their goo and burn them
down can't control my goo maybe we could
have some kind of initiative where it's
like if you
we're gonna hook you up you can smoke
all the crack you want
and take all the heroin and Fentanyl
whatever and then at the end you've got
just got to kill yourself
kind of a Vibe right
what a deal get like one week of Just
Vibe out live it up and then you got to
get in the suicide pod and say bye bye
and we're gonna turn you into goo
whatever that is you see this big news
oh yeah this is huge so breaking slavery
has officially been banned in Tennessee
what year is this
it is 20 20 22. that's of course uh
referring to
the 14th or fifth wishes well this is
actually so Tennessee and I believe four
other states had uh language similar to
what you're talking about in the uh U.S
Constitution about slavery being legal
as punishment for a crime a bunch of
States also had that same kind of thing
in them and I believe five states had
measures to remove
um slavery from their constitutions uh
including Oregon uh California's next
door neighbor here well the Constitution
still says slavery is legal for
prisoners yeah slavery still exists in
the United States it's called the prison
system which is how in prison they
literally force you to work and they pay
you like two cents an hour or something
13th Amendment thank you yeah it says it
says slavery is abolished except for in
the case of like prisoners or some [ __ ]
like that so yeah slavery is actually
still legal really in America and it has
been
yeah that's pretty incredible I just
love this graphic so much like a little
bit you decide yeah you decide slavery
that's awesome yo what kind of sap ass
loser is Katy Perry like [ __ ] you like
what yeah two days ago here I'm voting
for Rick Caruso and I'm proud of it what
does it take for all these celebrities
like he just invited them to some fancy
party and she probably was around
they've got to be rubbing shoulders and
then they're like cool I'll vote for you
and endorse you a hundred percent
Katie's got some Bops but uh I can
listen to the Glee version so it's fine
I guess she voted for measure 28 that
one passed overwhelmingly it's just fun
doing more arts and stuff in schools
okay whatever bye loser idiot
show me what you voted on on the stuff
about raising taxes on yourself that's
the one I want to see I thought they
told me she voted no on that one she
didn't show that one did she it's
probably a safe bet yeah there it is so
good stuff man here's what it says in
the 13th Amendment says neither slavery
nor involuntary servitude except as in a
punishment for Crime whereof the party
shall have been duly convicted shall
exist within the United States or any
place subject to their jurisdiction
have you been convicted of a crime then
your ass is a Slave
yep
that is so insane yes it is
[Applause]
kind of like a loophole of how they
still manage to
[Music]
continue to do it after slavery was um
abolished abolished um well it's not a
loophole it's right there in the
Constitution
you know what I mean
it's right there that is the amendment
that abolished yeah yeah
yeah they wrote that at [ __ ] in when
they blog I mean it's an improvement
don't get me wrong it's a step up from
the yes slavery yeah like at least you
have to be convicted of a crime no
guarantee let's go
um let's just go get everybody they're
all yeah well they did that actually
they're all criminal after uh yeah after
they freed the slaves a lot of people
just started rounding them up as
criminals and then forced them back into
slavery it's pretty very very [ __ ] up
actually there was a sheriff or someone
who was like they had to abolish slavery
on the state constitution on the ballot
and he's like listen I'm against did you
see that Dan can you find I was the one
that sent it to you it was my friend he
sent me a picture of the Oregon voters
guy pull it up I want to pull it up okay
they're like I just want to say for the
record we are against slavery that being
said that being said yeah if you
actually passed this it could really
[ __ ] up our prisons
we need slaves bro our business depends
on it oh my God basically that's what
they said
yeah I know
it's shocking that uh that a sheriff
would be uh pro-slavery this is the
screenshot that my uh my friend sent me
they start and end this argument in
opposition with Oregon sheriffs do not
get donor Sports slavery or involuntary
servitude of any form with that being
said
Oregon sheriffs cannot support measure
112 as drafted it creates unintended
consequences for Oregon jails that will
result in the elimination of all
reformative programs and increased costs
to local jail operates are you talking
about the one that says it's Banning
slavery together
because it sounds like you support
slavery then at the end I love they have
to reiterate because they know how bad
this sounds
it sounds to me like you're just cool
with slavery bro that's so messed up
he's like look I'm not against slavery
but it does benefit us greatly at the
moment
I mean you think you Shawshank
Redemption probably everyone's seen that
movie it's an American classic you've
seen how it works the the prison ward in
there it's getting massive Kickbacks
pocketing tons of cash because he's able
to sell the prisoners out as like cheap
labor and he's the one that takes the
money [ __ ] crazy dude
there it is
but overall great great a great great
outcome here on uh
on the midterms I saw Ben Shapiro
tweeted out from Red Wave to Red Wedding
pretty funny actually for Benny boy yeah
I like that was good huh yeah
um
let's move on and Joe Rogan said
something about the red
yeah he's yeah he said there's going to
be a red wave so big it's going to be
like that scene from The Shining when
the elevator opens and the blood comes
out
wishful thinking there Joe
but don't worry you got Greg Abbott to
represent you you're good
and Ted Cruz boy oh we got the best
representation in the whole world
my Representatives Ted Cruz when the
power goes out in the state he flies to
Cancun yeah that's only smart I wouldn't
want to be in this freezing ass State
neither but I ain't got the money
from Red Wave to and then the top
Communists how did Dr lose I don't
understand probably because he drinks
his own piss Ty you consider that
literally he did a segment about
drinking his own piss did you see that
segment Ty foreign
if you guys want more details we're
gonna get into details about all the
complaining that's going on and the salt
and the tears if you want to lick their
tears then join us tomorrow morning that
finally will be
I love that how did Dr Oz Lose the TV Dr
quack who spent his his career selling
[ __ ] unsubstantiated supplements
who literally doesn't even live in
Pennsylvania how did he lose lives in
[ __ ] New Jersey
all right let's move on to ratio
destroying uh ratio Elon Musk destroying
Twitter and getting ratio at heart so
good real quick speaking speaking of Dr
Oz the the person that brought him a
career Oprah endorsed John Federman
that's awesome like that that's just
yeah
yeah Oprah probably like Obi-Wan wishes
she could take that back
you know like he did not he strayed from
the like yeah Dr Oz is her Anakin it
definitely for sure
so let's talk about uh Elon Musk getting
ratioed and embarrassed on Twitter it's
very satisfying for me Elon Musk is a
piece of [ __ ] uh shirt is live till
Sunday on teddyfresh.com I can't show it
to you the website though yeah
so look at this huh
Elon Musk in 2017 let's see what he said
yeah oh this is me yeah we gotta
yeah
dude I was a huge fan of Elon back in
the day before he was like a public
figure and basically he had I was so
admiring what he had done with electric
vehicles yeah we were just sold on the
Tesla dream it was like here's this car
it's got the autopilot
um they're already ready for the full
auto drive but it's just not legal yet
but they already have the system in
place you can pay for it yeah it's crazy
and all this stuff and we totally bought
all that I feel like that's how everyone
felt at the time I think everyone that
doesn't like him now liked him back then
well majority of people I don't know
about Dan I totally didn't think that it
was just like like today I realized he's
just a salesperson yeah yeah and back
then it looked like he wasn't not only
that he's such an annoying [ __ ] too
yeah but back then kind of misleading
and my whole life I had this dream of
electric vehicles it's just amazing and
you looking at the world and you have
this problem of of uh fossil fuels being
finite and polluting the world and
you're wondering when is it going to
happen when are we going to have cars
that run on electricity and this guy
went he honestly he made what looked to
me like a miracle at the time and these
electric cars were starting to pop up
everywhere and it was just
um it was just amazing I was just so
I was so grateful and happy about it and
you know we got we're early adopters of
Tesla in fact Ela still has one but
that's going back in January we're
getting the new uh
we are gonna have two electric vehicles
and no Teslas that's awesome yeah we're
gonna have the Porsche and the BMW you
are going with the BMW Flats what's that
you're going with the BMW yeah yeah
I'm a beamer boy myself so love
I'm a little disappointed about the BMW
after watching the videos online
not the greatest design I'm down with it
I say you can take my pores I don't care
I'll drive it and I do love the Porsche
so I think we're gonna swap yeah it's
fine the coolest [ __ ] about that BMW is
the grill is like it's scratch proof so
if you put hot water on there it gets
any scratch or dings off I'll put that
to the test let's do that let's get an
ice pick or what's the model so I can
pull up a picture of it what's it called
um is it uh X
is it is
yeah something like that I expect yeah
yeah I mean I I think it's cool I don't
really care if I'm driving an electric
vehicle I'm happy so is it the is it a
SUV yeah yes you know this one yeah yeah
that's it
yeah well we were all excited and then
love was like actually I saw a video
where it says it sucks and he sent it to
you and she's like I'm canceling it and
I was like just take my car just take my
car because we've been waiting a year
for this thing on the waiting list take
my car dude the car itself is very very
good it's like BMW but there's like a
couple quirks that just annoys me yeah I
don't point that out I don't care about
that all right I'm a designer and it was
like really bad design did you features
in there I will say yeah from a design
standpoint I'm no designer but uh
compared to other cars that are the same
price I feel like they're lacking a
little bit sometimes did you look at the
Audi e-tron SUV we tried driving it a
while ago and it was kind of like an
ancient Beast inside it wasn't that like
it's not fully electric is it and I
don't think it was fully electric at
least I don't know if it's still the
same one we tried it like a year ago I
think anyway we're getting sidetracked
the point is is that yeah I was a huge
Elon Musk fan and I was just a big fan
of everything he was doing this is
before he was like a front-facing person
he was actually at the time kind of
elusive and he was like the shy sweet
almost like humble dude like a little
awkward yeah he was like like talking
whenever he talks publicly he's he it
was a thing where it's like oh he's so
shy to be in the public face he's not
comfortable talking publicly and it was
like almost this endearing thing yeah it
was like this
and so obviously so much has changed in
five years but here let's watch this
before he found out about memes
and that was the real beginning
bro that was the Killer
uh yeah
the title of the post is Ethan majorly
sucking elon's dick well that's true
that's true actually I don't even
dispute that no I remember this well and
that correct me if I'm wrong guys but I
think you even literally well let's just
what I offer did I offer that you were
close to it
that offer is rescinded
Elon Musk Elon Musk I love this guy man
what's the audio so bad is that what a
podcast sound like no I think the clip
is just oh uh it might have actually I
mean this was early early days we it was
probably before we bought the console
and we were just running off a cheap
little uh Behringer before exact mixer
it would have been before
um
I would probably if he was like yo Doug
here's my dick I knew it this was going
before you said it I wasn't you thought
I was gonna say suck he wants me to
shine it and manicure it I need you to
manscape my genitals and I'd be like
cool
resend it require payment
I love the guy all that requires a horse
in exchange
some people hate him I don't know why
is that the real life Tony Stark right
at the time the only people that hated
him were like contrarians who were like
I don't know there's some it seems like
everybody loved him and there's this
weird contrarian thing about him it
seemed like they were just trying to
push electric vehicles away because it
was gonna like mess with
their business
I'm sure there was an element of that
mm-hmm
I mean come on the guy's incredible yeah
he's he's he's pioneered
commercial space travel
opens the doors for so many things that
guy has made driving electric vehicles
cool to the point where he made a profit
and now he's so embarrassing so cringed
so so far those two things that you have
cited those those are true though you
know what I mean yeah like okay it's not
it's not the worst yeah I don't think
it's embarrassing at all you can't
change your opinion you know what I mean
no I yeah it's just in in context it's
sucking yeah the admiration for a guy
that I find gross now it did not age
yeah I mean what SpaceX is doing is yeah
yeah I mean it's objectively impressive
you know obviously if somebody clips and
be like what a hypocrite that's just so
[ __ ] stupid yeah like idiotic they
always are yeah Ethan's a hypocrite in
this in this 160p with [ __ ] up audio
ancient clip and he's saying elon's
awesome
we
'd much data in the past few years that
tell us
is like no longer even relevant mm-hmm
everyone used to love Kevin Spacey you
know what I'm saying
right that's a great point you are I
know it's I know it's controversial but
you are in fact allowed to change your
opinion about thing when presented with
new information I know it's kind of
insane but yeah oh it's actually in some
cultures and at certain times it was
even thought to be admirable to be
willing to change your mind on things
but not your fault I love changing my
mind
I know
yeah what's for dinner I don't know
changed my mind speaking of changing
your mind
you'll like what I just sent uh hope for
DeVito
I just joined and wanted to let you know
that I got no notification with the Tate
title and ignored it I got a second
notification when the title changed to
Danny in the Hot Chip and immediately
joined wait she got they got a second
notification
keep changing it dude just keep changing
it yo let's change it again but you
think it's true love no I I don't yeah
because why would they get another
vacation they're just making a joke I
think we'll blow everyone up so hard
yeah it's a joke
you guys are funny okay let's go keep
watching I'm consumable the model three
mark my do we need to watch this whole
thing no no no yeah yeah I know we get
the idea no
Twitter's a rat hole not because of you
I hate watching myself so
yeah so that's that okay but here's a
here's a album so okay people go people
like ninja and Philly D who did you
watch really do you talk about me no you
see what that Judas had to say about me
he offered me a book that said here's
don't be stupid stupid he's like what's
the deal everyone expected to get banned
and now you're complaining about it none
of that happened
alive and well just just so you know
none of that happened what that's what
he said he didn't get me he didn't get
me a book that said he didn't wait what
why are you lying because I explained
all this to you the other day yeah you
really have to go through it again Dan
is happening dance [ __ ] lying why are
you running defense right now for Phil
you're Philly apologize you apologize I
sent it I sent it right now I'm Discord
I apologize no I'm not that is right
here
who is right love
I edited that [ __ ] social media clip
tomorrow because I wanted to slam Philly
then I noticed he's obviously saying
that
you did it on purpose so you're not one
of the dumb ones exactly 100
and I was on your side fully yesterday
okay hold on let's watch it let's watch
it because maybe maybe I was wrong about
Philly we made our mistake I've been
going pretty hard let's see
you're going hard without it's just
checking it's just in general well well
hold on because can we have any friends
left over
in the world playful ribbon
please
Danger on the other hand is dead to me
he's dead to me but let's see what
Philly said bastards welcome back to the
Philip DeFranco show buckle up make sure
you hit that like button and let's just
jump into the news starting with Ethan
Klein got nuked off the internet oh yeah
he goes Ethan got nuked from orbit
it's time on Twitter and it's because of
Elon Musk just a little over a week ago
after Elon Musk took over the platform
he declared that he lost it yeah he
looks great really looks great skinny
Legend he's inspiring we love Philly for
that with that being said he definitely
called you fat though yeah
okay let me just watch this thing how
legal on Twitter but he is seemingly
unveiled that he is not an absolutist
about that or that there sometimes have
to be limitations to that rule
specifically impersonations and the key
thing with this story is people
impersonating Elon Musk right since his
takeover it's been a big trend for
verified people to change their name and
photo to Elon musk's and tweet something
absurd or out of character but here's
the thing and you may not expect it it
makes complete sense why these people
were suspended has always been against
Twitter's rules so it wasn't surprising
to see this happen to the accounts and I
have to imagine a number of the people
that were banned including Ethan were
expecting this I mean even Ethan's own
fans were like he's going for the band
or for anyone that okay okay he says you
expected it okay let's see what happens
good did this and didn't expect to get
banned I got a beautiful book for you to
buy the week of Thanksgiving okay the
book was not for me the book's not for
you the book's not for me thank you
rewind get a book but but any titles
this next video I'm sorry oh
well you're next I'm sorry bio and in
the name okay all right maybe maybe I
misinterpreted that Philly here let me
text him I gotta end a tick tock to send
him an apology wait it's The Tick tock's
still up yeah it's still whoa hey guys
we'll see you on uh
we'll see you guys on uh tomorrow
Thursday yeah all right thanks everybody
yo I'm gonna text Philly
for those of you guys who found the Vlog
to be offensive I'm sorry you did really
I'm sorry
misunderstood what you said the book
wasn't for me
[Music]
thank you now yeah thank you for not
giving me that book bro
sorry
need that book bro I'm very sorry
very sorry
don't forget about the new comment
though
say what the name yeah
ask him why are you why are you
instigating yeah what did he say what
did you say love nothing say it
say it he nuked you from orbit
that being said I don't appreciate being
called fat no no just ask that being
said what did you mean by orbit I don't
I don't appreciate you saying I have my
own orbit sorry I don't appreciate you
saying maybe just maybe again he knows I
understand he knows I'm that one's a
joke so I said Philly I'm afraid I can't
do that I said Philly I'm sorry I
misunderstood what you said the book
wasn't for me thank you for not giving
me that book bro I'm very sorry for the
misunderstanding that being said I don't
appreciate you saying I have my own
orbit
just being honest kind of sounds like a
compliment you've got your own orbit
that's a complimentary you run the world
the next mystery that you live in as if
he was talking about you in his apology
video yeah you keep you really want me
to watch that I really want you to watch
it because I'm curious I'm more curious
about this one he does he's not I've
seen it he just says I'm sorry about
something I don't know why you're so
gung-ho right you're in the town now or
is that different
uh oh that's different okay
sup you beautiful bastards welcome back
to the Philip DeFranco show hope you
have a fantastic and yes it is what 21
seconds
it's true I would have been at 21
seconds already I am wearing the same
hoodie for three days in a row whether
here right now is cold and wet and yeah
I don't want to watch this ad
skip to 21 seconds
hit that like button and let's just jump
into it starting with I'm sorry also
that might be confusing I'm not sorry
what your mother and I did was a
beautiful thing that I do not regret
rather true Jordy is sorry
this is a little cheeky yeah I don't
know you know I'm fine with all that
no problem okay
you really think that he thought I would
interpret that like for me
I don't know I just felt like you needed
all the contacts before you said you
forgive him
but okay let me text him back about the
apology fake apology no
we love Philly where the [ __ ] were we
dude we're even we were at Elon Moore Ma
you don't mind
dude I'm so hungry here I don't but
you're not gonna like it yeah I don't
think I'll like it but I'll take a bite
feel famished I ate yesterday like not a
lot of calories
and then exercise it's kind of gnarly
it's not bad it's just a little bit
gnarly
healthy
yeah gnarly I like it
it's actually kind of Gonna Hate that's
good okay
I just needed a couple bites
so
yeah what I wanted to say is that people
like ninja I'm not even gonna say filthy
anymore he's off the hook
and a bunch of um conservatives are like
you have to put and Dan said you have to
put
Perry Dan was just trying to tell you
the rules Dan was like you got them
because you didn't put Beauty in your
name dude
in your name bro okay well here's that I
just like that too so look at this
Elon Musk parody
uh banned right
but obviously he tried to make it like
to the back but like still shut the [ __ ]
up okay Elon Musk
comedy is now uh legal on Twitter my
wife left me
that one says real but that's like it's
so so obvious are you this isn't that
one that's saying oh you guys are stupid
just play by the rules it's like yeah we
get it but it's stupid like this is
exactly why you want to start seeing
like Elon Musk real and then like
somebody telling a joke and then writing
joke in parentheses yeah and like it
it's I was saying to you guys it's
becoming like YouTube titles where you
guys say like emotional motion right
it's like no this is just stupid this is
people reacting to dumb [ __ ] well also
Elon really only cares about this since
people started goofing on him yeah this
is literally in response to him being
fragile it's so pathetic yeah 100 it is
my wife left me Elon Musk and Prince
he's real I'm sorry that's funny I just
clearly not Elon Musk and Elon Musk
would never use this photo I know right
so like lame [ __ ] losers but also Mr
Elon Musk the meme Edge Lord yeah
exactly if you're so edgy and so funny
why can't you take a joke you can't
like what the [ __ ]
moving on it gets even worse okay
this one got banned look at the name
it's like typed with letters and numbers
and not verified
bam yeah this is just pathetic
impersonators are dangerous
in the words of nature it's not funny
also people uh like I saw how it was
like written in an article like he's
suspending impressionators or whatever
and it's like no these are regular
people that are just making a joke it's
not like you're trying to go to the DMV
Elon Musk ID right I don't know it's
like this is different right I'm not
trying to sell that Elon Musk water
the joke is that people know who you are
and at first glance it looks like Elon
Musk but it's not like do we really need
to explain the joke it's I had 2.3
million followers it's just so dumb
whatever happened to the handle my
handle was at a series reproductions how
can I impersonate you if my handle is
not Elon Musk
but this one the name is not even
how is this getting banned this is
pathetic okay
um
Elon Musk is now suspending parity
accounts look at here's this one
completely compliant
it has parody in the [ __ ] title and a
rainbow in the front band so how do you
explain this one I agree they're not
yeah they're they're mudding the waters
big time yeah they're so pathetic and I
agree that it is happening because he's
fragile yeah I was never defending him
on it I was just saying
that they're obviously
cracking down on people making fun of
you alone on the app and that the way
that you had done it was going to get
you banned I knew that it'd be sad
I know that but
um I was gonna do it myself too by the
way when Ethan was doing it a lot of
people were tweeting me like is take his
phone he's at it again which is always
the joke when you go wild but this time
I was totally on board I thought it was
funny anything Ethan said I know I might
get banned it's fine with me I was happy
with that because Ethan off of Twitter
better for me yeah win win that's what
I'm saying
I mean I know but I was gonna do it
myself too I was busy putting theater to
sleep and I kind of like missed the
moment but I wanted to tweet something
about abortions I thought it was going
to be funny
yeah I know I was I was in the lab I had
a good one for you it was like um
it was going to be something like
I am a pro
I'm pro-choice because
if abortion was banned I'd have 15 kids
kind of funny yeah pretty good
it's a Wild Thing from the Tweet oh well
this one uh yeah this one's completely
compliant and again this is the guy who
says comedy is now legal on Twitter and
he is the most punitive
like if you people thought about Twitter
as like this how could he actually say
that and then do this like I'm sorry to
everyone that's supporting him usually
isn't it like people who are like all
about logic like he's conservatives
they're all loving it I guess because
now he's bridge to that world yeah but
but I think he lost a lot of like the
actual he's losing him more and more the
chip it away but this this last one
doesn't show parity but it just
demonstrates that even something so
playful as this can get you banned
yeah this one got banned sorry Elan to
tell you what is actually funny because
obviously you're posting like cringe
memes do you think they're funny this is
funny it is funny it is very funny and
so I think you should ban anybody
posting cringy memes like yourself ban
nine gag memes
uh dumbass goodbye instead of hello you
know what goodbye ninja goodbye you know
what about Ninja
honestly I can't have someone that bad
at Fortnight on the show like the way he
was missing those shots he needs to step
up his game before you come on this show
yeah
too far bro you saw miss those shots
with no excuse uh Ian goodbye goodbye
goodbye maybe you need to read the book
I will I will I will
but it the ultimate irony is that
everyone think of Twitter as this like
super
controlling
way too like ban heavy and [ __ ] and then
the minute he comes in he becomes way
more punitive than they ever were
accounts are getting expanded and
blocked and shipped and um
it's [ __ ] pathetic yeah so there it
is [ __ ] you uh you're a loser moving on
the second check mark we talked about
that
tweet a meme of a Nazi Soldier he did
that
let's check out this Elon Musk one
Elon Musk post a video of a Nazi
followed by a post
telling people to vote Republican
what how times have changed I didn't
really frankly even get this maybe you
guys can explain it to me are they like
carrier pigeons it's because they're
birds like the Twitter bird and that's
the unread messages uh counter on the
corner
people used to send messages via bird
what's the joke it's just it's a boomer
meme you know what I mean but
uh yeah I don't think he realized that
that was a um Nazi soldier that he was
using for his jokes a little awkward
where did he get this
he's a person gag because he gets those
memes fed to him yeah the person who
made this meme typed Nazi Soldier yeah
I feel like um people often call like
the richest person the the most powerful
man in the world but the most powerful
man in the world is whoever is in that
mean group shot
yeah
I don't think he's like too dumb to
understand what that even means or could
mean
whoever is in that group chat though
probably guys
yeah it's something like that
hey you liked it I ate it all
I told you I changed my mind
and then uh 30 minutes later we looked
at this but yeah he said I recommend
everybody vote Republican
because
shared power curbs the worst excesses of
both parties
it says a week after taking Twitter
private and becoming yeah seriously what
I vote for getting rid of it works
what is he talking about
foreign
well I mean
you know the sentiment I guess kind of
makes sense what he's saying although in
the context of American politics is
obviously a joke but it does yeah but he
also just doesn't believe in that I mean
he runs his company as an authoritarian
he doesn't share power so
well this is my favorite thing that
happened to ELO on Twitter
um
this week this French streamer who I
don't know who is but I love now our
cunier ratio Elon
so [ __ ] hard he erased his tweet in
shame he said what do you call someone
who is a master at baiting and I'm sorry
Elon that is so embarrassing you are so
embarrassing for that
that should be something to get banned
for yeah that's the first day of sixth
grade joke yeah yeah do you think he's
got like a group of people sitting
around him
I think this one is a Moscow original oh
so he's like oh I should tweet that I
think he thought that was so smart
imagine liking that tweet though it's
even worse than posting it
yeah and so this guy he says I don't
know but call this ratio and he actually
successfully ratioed Elon Musk and then
what's fascinating is Elon Musk erased
the [ __ ] tweet and shame
which is so embarrassing just on its
face right
here it is so you can see deleted by
author
and then he came back
and it ratioed him again look at this
oh my god dude he got this Twitter is
the worst but also the best he says and
the same guy
says where are you going take this ratio
again and don't delete it this time and
a ratio is as hard oh my god look how
many likes
yeah wow
that's crazy man so that was good
that was good
so there you go shout out to the French
framer
um
yeah I don't know
he's Monsieur to me
oh miss yeah to me
uh the quartering had a meltdown about
us
love
yeah he's upset tell me more wait should
we watch the we prepared something
should we do that first or after
um
I was originally thinking after but
playing it first
I don't know cam you made it what do you
think uh I would vote for after I think
okay after yeah that was my original
thought this one was called uh it
actually didn't have me in the title but
I used this photo
he has the craziest thumbnails ever we
always talk about it uh Ethan Klein
busted lying about Twitter ban what is
the Seattle by Elon Musk team
wait what what did he do here it's like
a tear yeah it's really weird and that's
supposed to be on being collected oh
yeah yeah yeah my gears yeah that's so
wild
wait what does he mean Ethan Klein
busted lying about Twitter banned by
Elon Musk team
as H3 podcast hosts spirals
what are you watching the same show
you're busted and then here uh Ethan
Klein permanently banned by Elon Musk
exclamation mark the A3 podcast host
goes full meltdown on Twitter that's
like the same exact title practically I
bet you those get him a lot of views
though I bet you
these were back to back three days in a
row
here you want let's watch it
actually having said that Elon Musk has
been in
[Music]
um
49 thumbnails in the past 30 days
look at that this his thumbnails are
nuts dude yeah
that's his real talent
I don't know if it's not him yeah yeah
no he's on there we gotta get a hold of
his thumbnail guys yeah if you're
watching and you make the thumbnails for
the quartering Channel hit us up I'll
double your pay your true Talent
whatever he's paying I'll double it
doing better things
I'm the guy you got a real talent you
could be making a difference in this
world
here's a time stamp of one of the videos
uh that he's very upset at me about that
these people like he immediately ran to
uh the H3 podcast
Twitter account to angrily tweeted not
me I did not tweet that bro dumb I'm not
even logged into that Twitter account
about it these people extended Twitter
dude Jeremy okay I'm losing my mind let
me go back a little bit Jeremy before I
watch this he has notorious for saying
Twitter is bad and I'm quitting it he's
done that like five times and he comes
back the next day every time he's such a
pathetic Twitter freak and you're so
projecting bro well he'll also people
um that he claims is not him
run his account oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but he always gets too drunk
and then forgets that he said that and
just starts tweeting it as himself at
some point like at like one in the
morning the next day by the way yeah he
got a ton of views on this 600 000
because he posts like five videos a day
yeah so pathetic man it's so sad to pee
in my trash can it's so easy if you're
conservative you literally just put me
in the title now and some like make up
some alternate reality about how I'm
crying or upset or melting down I get so
many views it's crazy dude it's crazy
was he just selling coffee for also
what are you doing bro coffee enema
that's the only thing your coffee's fit
for use I mean he just he probably makes
decent money doing it selling it I mean
that's part of the conservative gift
right they all white label some products
yeah I guess it's not as bad as selling
like a slot bucket one of his pin
comments says uh Ethan try my coffee
oh really yeah in one of his videos that
I was watching I had unfortunately had
to watch a lot of them uh he was
offering you a brand ambassadorship for
his shitty coffee friend okay
interesting I don't know if he can
afford me yeah
were exclusive to fiddlehead right
exactly we represent fiddlehead dude I'm
[ __ ] myself
ah [ __ ] idiot
and at least suspended for 2.3 million
followers dumb and and also let me say
this
I and you could tell that these people
like he immediately ran to uh the H3
podcast
Twitter account to angrily tweet about
it bro it wasn't really really not at
all what happened the Tweet was a joke
yeah he did he doesn't show the Tweet of
course right because he's like he makes
it sound like I went over there and I
was like ah this is unfair Elon Musk
it's not happen at all and it wasn't
even me by the way these people are
addicted to Twitter these people
permanently and this is let's see how
many times you know what let me go see
how much Jeremy has tweeted today let me
go see how many times he's tweeted by
the way the most people that I see who
are like manically obsessed with Twitter
is like let's see Jordan Peterson yes
like sick [ __ ] amounts of posting the
quartering Donald Trump
all right Ben Shapiro Elon Musk who who
what do we have in common here one two
the Luna takes these people
a lot of his videos too
um when reporting on controversies and
stuff were just him reacting to your
replies on Twitter too so he's probably
super pissed at his main
reports are gone just lost a lot of
content I just cost her ass a shed bro
I'm sorry
oh yeah
can I get a countdown
oh my God hey remember how quartering
had a his original channel was trying to
get kids to send them send him mail so
he could email them or mail them candy
and toys that he wanted an arcade wait
what are you talking about yeah I know I
know just uh in the drain
his first hobby was um
he was making a Channel about going to
arcades and playing all the games there
he's a claw okay a machine fanatic and
he was like guys watching send me your
address and I'll hook you guys up
he was not joking that was dead serious
um
I'm just here counting by the way you're
counting how many times he's quit
Twitter no how many times he's tweeted
in the last 24 hours oh wow
but this does piss me off look at the
amount of views one day ago 60 000 light
are views okay one day ago eighty
thousand and here's the one about me 600
000.
it's [ __ ] annoying
the circle jerk here's another one two
hundred and fifty thousand
yeah he's sad he's gonna be at a loss
without my Twitter account man every
time I tweet you basically make a video
of it no matter what I say
the biggest cope we've seen since the
2016 election you've tweeted 69 times in
the last 24 hours well I've seen nine
times are you serious yes that is
[ __ ] dude projection doesn't begin to
describe what's happening here I just
went through and hand counted since
tweeted how does he do anything else
just waiting that makes me I don't know
about Elon too yeah certainly not
spending time with his wife
have you ever tweeted close to 70 times
I was been tweeting leading up to my
band like once a week
17 times a day will rot my brain
good being on Twitter that much since
people are obsessed with Twitter that's
what he said he's critically obsessed
and he's just so pissed and coping
you only tweet a hundred times per day
is there really a limit yeah I think
that at least it used to be that's why
people go to like Twitter jail or
something like that you put in tweets
because they're spamming it maybe got
picked up as fam at that point dude he
tweets so much he's almost considered
spam right
by the way he uh he paid for
verification today as well oh what a
hear me of course we love you Jeremy
what a [ __ ] idiot welcome you are
into such great company as a b and Zach
Steve Rossi is going to call you anytime
now commanded you yeah
it's so funny but the quartering
actually no offense I know you you guys
are personalities but the quartering's
been around for a long time and he has a
Channel with 1.3 million Subs it's
awesome that he's not verified it's 100
tweets per hour oh okay well yeah it was
yeah that's pretty critical
um
but yeah I was talking about this before
he became a conservative uh hack he was
lit he looks like he's in prison I mean
that's what's crazy about it hey guys
I'm in jail for uh for uh child
molestation uh anyway it does look like
a mug shot yeah he looks like he's in
prison but watch this ELO I can't get
this is my favorite it's claustra I
can't get away I'm Jeremy and you've
come to that part of YouTube where you
might Be Wondering six years ago
together with my beautiful wife and our
best friend Brandon we're about as
obsessed with the arcade as anyone
specifically claw machines so obsessed
in fact that we've already bought four
different machines and have them in our
house no way he's talking to Children
the way he's like wow in the part of my
basement where you're wondering how did
you get here
I have a red flag that's what I'm saying
for somebody to have Clown Machines in
the house yes like who looks like that
yeah four of them that's
four whole claw machine he's got to fill
it up with his own prizes yeah he has to
he has to buy the prizes he got a price
the prizes for himself I don't know
something about it that just kind of
like gives me the the EQ Vibe that's
what I'm saying and um you know this is
the guy that conservatives look to for
political commentary that's crazy
my wife and my wife's boyfriend Brandon
wait let me go back let me go back
get out here together with my beautiful
wife and our best friend Brandon oh yeah
yeah yeah with my wife and my wife's
boyfriend Brandon totally let's go
Brandon dude what now let me predict the
next quartering video
he's gonna make a video titled Ethan
Klein goes after my wife yeah guaranteed
that's what he always does anytime I
joke like this so [ __ ] calling it
right now he's gonna make a video about
this and be and then act all outraged
like he went after my wife and he always
complains when people attack Ela and now
he's attacking my wife and just do this
whole [ __ ] thing he'll probably get
like 300 000 views for that so that's
good we're about to as well
should be clear
nothing no issue with his wife once I've
never said a single back I know the
whole big thing about his wife ever she
looks pretty nice yeah she looks nice
she's pretty
and her boyfriend seems like a nice guy
too
specifically claw machines so obsessed
in fact that we've already bought four
different machines that have them in our
houses
yeah hey kid you want to come in my van
yeah I've got claw machines at my house
yeah I got four of them
there's candy inside you want to play
we record our Journeys as we travel
across the country trying to win as many
prizes as humanly possible we'll also
show you how these machines work what to
look forward
we're going to show you how to win
massive tickets at a time my claw
machines are in my Breeze shed you guys
want to come play there
[Music]
a lot of different arcade games so you
can get that super sweet loot that you
want there's another reason to subscribe
we also do giveaways we'll ship the
prizes anywhere in the world if you see
us winning on this channel I can't
believe how he's talking yeah just give
me your address kind of sounds like Tim
and Eric we'll save the prices anywhere
in the world this shot is giving me
straight up filmed in prison he's even
got like the jumpsuit on
crazy
like it is straight from prison
I can't believe how prison this is
giving me
yeah that like really clicked in my
brain yeah it looks like he's wearing an
orange jumpsuit oh man and the green
screen bit is so easy for edits yeah you
don't even have to dude okay it looks
like he's about to pick up the telephone
off the wall yeah
laughs
part of the cloth struck crew I get
notified each and every time we upload a
new super fun video by crushing that
subscribe button today
you know what to give me you know how
Adolf Hitler he first wanted to be a
painter and then when that didn't work
out he just said I'm gonna kill all the
Jews so quartering has kind of a similar
story arc he's like I just want to make
claw videos and that didn't work out he
said I'm gonna kill all the Jews no I'm
just kidding he became a conservative
[ __ ] bag where he just is like a total
reactionary freak all right Jeremy time
to get back to your cell
okay back in the cell buddy there's no
stop talking about claw machines bro
there's no claw machines in prison
I'm [ __ ] my pants
such a loser dude
yo I bet that woman was his cousin or
some [ __ ] there's no way he's married
yo no way is this real
what
somebody Philip DeFranco somebody named
Philip DeFranco I don't know if it's the
real account or not just donated ten
dollars and said Dan is greater than
wait wait wait well you can confirm if
it's real or not it has a check mark on
it yeah I don't see that it's Philly it
is Philly
it's not showing
them I got it I got it okay you can
click his account and see if it goes to
his channel can't you let's see here
Bill are you gonna come into my chat and
[ __ ] please
you know man Phil
come on bro yeah why does it not
I'm in the back end and it doesn't show
the check mark it's bizarre this is what
it looks like for me
I choose to believe that was a fake
really really
what do you think about the quartering
uh soliciting uh dresses from kids from
prison
don't put him in that position uh he's
gonna sit on the fence on that one don't
rope him into the corner
what do you guys think I'm not sure what
how do you guys feel about soliciting
addresses from kids from prison tell me
what you think of the comments
all right let's keep watching hey Phil
it feels like I can't even leave a
comment
I'm gonna maintain friendships here on
YouTube Ethan we're friends which is the
playful banter we text we're good trust
me
okay we're dogs trust me
do you go on Hikes together there's a
year of squashing beef good it's all
gone to [ __ ] I'm gonna piss that ninja
oh speaking of texting by the way uh I
got reached out to uh by
um by amaranth I guess she went to go
message you and then saw and you guys
normally talked on Twitter yeah all
right [ __ ] I wonder who else I'm gonna
lose contact that's true so uh better
start talking my Instagram DMS yeah
that's funny because
I got that message too and I thought it
was fake at first because of all the
fake blue checks from oh you got it from
on Twitter oh okay right right
wow so the verification process is going
really good for you
you're getting you're getting messages
from real people and you think it's fake
sounds like it's working out
but Ethan's gonna try to convince people
of is that he meant to do it that he was
proving a point oh my God could it be
more obvious
could it be more obvious from the
beginning that that was what I was doing
uh oh hey idiot that
one doesn't allow comedy wrong
because when Ethan Klein was doing these
tweets last night
he didn't even bother read the terms of
service and I'm going to explain it all
to you uh-oh nice and clearly
you think I've banned on Twitter after
mocking Elon Musk over verification fast
go again desereto incorrect
yeah the quartering is now a Twitter
terms of service
so much how they're all [ __ ] wanking
off to terms of service right now even
though that's what everybody says now
it's like the one topic that they can
repeat well it's just hypocritical as
[ __ ] because for years we've been
hearing the bitching about like these
unfair bands
the people getting banned who clearly
violated terms of service and now all of
a sudden it's just like well you got to
follow the rules yeah you didn't put
parity in the title yeah you forgot to
put parity in there that is that has
been the disc like the the way it
flipped like overnight is Donald Trump
Donald Trump's like I want you all to go
to I want you all to go to the house and
kill everybody there
Trump was unfairly bad Ethan did a book
parody in the title right
such a [ __ ] idiot
Twitter's all right 600
000 views there you have it
yeah uh cheers go play the [ __ ] claw
machine you little [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
well
you're being pretty harsh yeah and I
feel like you should Reserve judgment
until you see this video that we put
together okay you know what first of all
pedo's a joke let's not throw around the
Pew well it's a Well he looks like one
looks like one
what he's wait I can't say that I mean
okay you can say whatever if Dan gets if
Dan gets uneasy I just pull back I don't
like throwing it around it's pretty
heavy he looks like he's okay fail and
he's asking kids listen listen when
you're saying it it all adds up do them
yeah when you're when you're saying it
in the context of the video he's talking
about children's games while looking
like he's wearing a prison jumpsuit in
what appears to be a mug shot then the
joke yeah makes sense but if you're just
like ah this guy looks like a pedo that
that's that that's what I'm saying let's
just spent a [ __ ] like 20 minutes
if I speak I am in a mugshot he's
wearing a jumpsuit big trouble and I
don't want to be in big trouble
all right thank you so anyway before I
um
before I pass judgment let's roll uh
this video and see if I'll change my
mind
thank you by the way guys is it for me
do I need to play it
yeah I think it's just in the dock right
I thought you guys queued it up
here it is
all right
I am
for obviously you know freedom freedom
of speech and when push comes to shove
you know I would back fine in this and
it was a it was a it was an amazing uh
three hour and 33 Minute Podcast you
know not a bad viewership 499 000 views
that's pretty good uh but uh humble
break my video announcing his band beat
his video so far I'm sure his will
surpass mine in time of course he
usually gets like 700 to a million he's
got three times with my subscribers
turns out I turned I tuned into a stream
last time he had like 40 000 people
watching him that's incredible
um I saw he had a lot of hundred dollar
super chats he made a lot of money he
had a lot of new members you think line
is still an important voice in YouTube
space Ethan Klein can have the
quartering is a little IQ inbred loser
as a title in his video
Ah that's a good title I'm sorry but
that's a [ __ ] good title Jeremy you
have to admit that is a fire title
yeah you said you're an important voice
right before it you know
by the way by the way I love this side
of him
IQ inbred loser he's giving me a little
ad space too did you notice yeah no it's
super nice yeah pettyfresh.com you can
get the Elon Musk is a piece of [ __ ]
shirt yeah super nice of him to do that
I like when he got all bashful after he
was like I beat him but he's probably
gonna need him he's gonna eat that thing
no this all came up well let's finish
video place in the YouTube space Ethan
Klein can have the quartering is a
little IQ inbred loser as a title in his
video I think that Ethan Klein could
still do a lot of good in this world up
to the guy and I'm not even one of those
people like oh I missed the old H3 you
know per se people change people grow
people are allowed to you know do that
oh is so sweet it's so understanding
lost his Ryan Kavanaugh again has
nothing to do with this I support you
against him thank you brother I don't
like when people uh make fun of his uh
wife that's not okay if I ever did it in
the past that's not okay and I apologize
for that
um sometimes you don't get caught up in
the memes and that's not okay I do and I
wanna I say this you know to be clear
I wish the best for him and if this is
the road that he wants to take
I wish him all the best thanks bro damn
that was actually special yeah so we we
were going through all of his recent
videos that have you in the title or
whatever and Olivia started noticing she
found like three moments where he was
suddenly being like kind of a sweetheart
yes and Olivia was touched she was she
was like genuinely touched and then we
came we were like cam you gotta we gotta
get all these moments and compile it
into like an Ethan tribute video damn
that was really nice there would just be
like beacons in his video of like
beautiful positive moments where I was
like who I like this guy yeah Olivia was
like oh my God he's got mocha coffee I
want to buy it no he was talking he was
talking about the coffee he has after I
watched him obviously compliment you so
many times he was like my favorite this
this fall is blueberry cobbler or
blueberry cobbler coffee rocks and also
our apple pie one and I just loved it
hold the phone no blueberry cobbler
coffee that's what I'm
curious about it that's all I'm saying
let's try Olivia came in today and she's
like you know what Captain Marvel kind
of [ __ ] sucked I [ __ ] hate Brie
Larson right because I watched that last
night she just binged all the quartering
videos last night got red built you know
what that was really touching and I
actually you know what you don't look
like a pedo thank you for saying yeah I
agree I think we can safely say either
low in low IQ inbred sweetheart
that one is more acceptable low IQ
inbred weirdo
I don't know I don't know where the line
is how about that either low IQ we were
asking if it was fine right and bread I
mean fine yeah really fine I guess I
don't know
uh people asking if this was real I mean
it was it was chopped up a little bit
obviously and some and cam added the
teddy fresh to the sidebar that wasn't
real but uh but the sentiment of what he
was saying that was all real there were
genuine compliments that's interesting
yeah I got a little creative with it
like when he said um people can change
their mind he immediately goes after
that but Ethan's going in a poisonous
Direction he sucks
I think I think he has a tendency to
want to look like uh like partial or
enlightened so he go he'll spend like
nine minutes talking about what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I am and then be like but
you know he he he he's done a lot of
good things and then what cam cuts out
he's like but he's a [ __ ] ass but
he's like yeah exactly now he's a net
negative and I hate him poor that's
great though not powerful beautiful
go [ __ ] yourself Jeremy
for real yeah
actually Jeremy's actually pissed about
the election though oh apparently what
happened in Wisconsin he's so angry
about
uh uh I believe the governor's race uh
is what he was about one yeah
he reposted a post to Facebook yeah vibe
you dumb [ __ ] really cast your bout
Forevers you guys the guy that made your
loved ones die alone at hospitals that
made you attend drive-through
graduations and funerals to destroy
local business I mean I'm fine thriving
even I love that I'm fine I'm thriving
but you [ __ ] idiots who voted for
this guy deserve all the Strife coming
your way how the [ __ ] can you forget
what he did to you all the lies holy
[ __ ] Wisconsin is dumb as [ __ ] and then
he he actually screen capped that and
then tweeted it was interesting see it's
interesting he's always saying that
you're melting down that's a Melton like
that you could qualify as a meltdown
like he's melting down about something
he literally clearly very arriving I'm
fine I'm thriving yeah I don't care and
he he supplement it's cool I'm coping
for sure but I'm 100 fine okay good
we're worried about you oh so oh oh my
God I didn't understand so that's his
post yeah that's his post Oh I thought
it's just like a comment that he liked
from Facebook
oh my God so he's saying all that yeah
what it's like
he's unwell he's unwell yeah we wish him
the best yeah you get that sweetheart
he's a sweetheart he is kind of a
sweetheart with a stinky ass crotch but
that's okay sure it can be you have to
shower more than you know every other
day I mean once a week is Gen not enough
for a guy of your kind of build and hair
you know dude I'm [ __ ] myself
anyway
can I ask a question just to get clarif
clarity you're saying I can't say
somebody no I'm I'm just genuinely
interested in this conversation not on
not online live I think if you if you
look because see someone looks like a
pet no I don't think so I I think that's
way too far yeah it's a
yeah because that's just purely you're
saying because of the way that you look
you are this terrible thing that's
that's not cool again that's why I said
when you have the Nuance of like here's
a guy making claw machine videos for
kids looking like he's in a prison
jumpsuit in a mug shot
then there's like a comedic through line
there that isn't just purely about his
appearance you know what I mean but when
you just throw it out and I know that
was the context that you met it in but
that could easily be clipped out without
that context and just be like hey look
he's just making wild accusations about
pedophilia right now and yeah I I just
okay no I hear what you're saying it
just I don't know okay
can we do a poll the audience is very
much not with you on let's still fall
I'm curious
okay is it is it just say is it over the
line
to say somebody looks like a pedo yes or
no curious should we just write is it
over the line yes or no instead of oh
sure yeah that we're talking about
keyword you say b word uh thank you
Bella Simmons 50 gifted this is actually
good for me this this is good for me to
know you know what I mean thank you
Bella Simmons for the 50 gifted that's
so cool everyone still gets so stoked
150 coming I thought it was free
yeah I thought it was free speech I
thought comedy was alive and well
ninja okay so here we go I'm learning
something I'm growing as a human being
here we are It's Over The Line knowledge
you cannot say somebody looks like a
pedo
it's over the line it's inappropriate
not cool I I shouldn't say it I'm gonna
say something I don't I I probably
shouldn't thank you Joe because I'm but
it's good I'm not yeah okay okay cool I
get it it's too far it's too much there
it is yeah yeah yeah
trying to think but nothing happens yeah
uh here whoa this next one is so wild
wild so so wild
it's kind of hard to watch but oh wait
you skipped wait I did you skipped one
last
special little thing that we did for
this uh quarter oh yeah I'm so sorry I
forgot yeah so we were so captivated by
the quarterings thumbnails as you guys
know we're huge fans I mean they're one
of the craziest genuinely so all you
guys back here a lot of you guys took
your own crack at making quartering
stuff thumbnail and so here let's take
do we know who made each one yeah yeah
so who made this one uh I did I love it
so it's really good they ate the Hot
Chip
I think it's really good I think it
could work good for a highlight love
yeah that was kind of the idea is we all
of these are um you know made for the
topics from today's episode uh so
they're all relevant highlight Clips
potentially
I think it's great I love it going down
ninjas total meltdown
this one's then yeah this one's pretty
good but I think this one's more Manic
and crazy but it's good it's good
uh his tooth is Brie Larson by the way
that's ABS by the way wait what that's
Captain it's a little it's a little
Easter egg oh okay okay I see it I had
to zoom in a lot
quartering loses his mind his wife
Jeremy did what plane ride gone wrong
what the [ __ ] can you guess who made
that one
Zach you got it yeah okay
well it's a good try Zach
it's a nice try I love just the Walmart
logo oh yeah it's all his favorite
things yeah drains pizza at Walmart
watching his wife kick I was wanting to
make one but I forgot I always went
downstairs and I started playing God of
War and I drain and Walmart I've been
sitting in Walmart drains yes yes yes
and what's the pizza oh the pizza
without me all right yeah what's the
half circle next to it oh that's a two
plain windows so he's watching his Pilot
wife oh yeah I forgot about that story
okay so he's getting cocked
that's them making out in the window
yeah okay okay I like that I like that
that's good
this one is looking very very genuine
you haven't got the same teardrop Elon
pissed himself ratio this one's great
this one is like basically
and the thing is there's so many details
you have to kind of look at is you got
the diaper on the head
this one's right on man right on oh this
one's good too man child meltdown wow
wow this one is right on and you even
got like the sjw
he's drooling so that one's cams and the
previous one was Ian's yes you guys all
wait did Sam do one uh no okay yeah I
mean uh
who did this one me
yeah that one was pretty good that's all
good there's a direct correlation with
Photoshop uh yeah who knows Photoshop
dude I was I was like walking from Dan
to cam annoying because I haven't used
Photoshop in so long as I do stuff
actually I kind of want to test my skill
because I've been I've been working more
in Photoshop yeah I'm better at it which
is something I always wanted to do so I
really I'm gonna try to make one uh and
still bring it in yeah I want to test my
my skills here maybe Zach could help if
you need
yes I actually didn't use Photoshop
not surprised yeah
because I think it's a lot of advanced
to get the text warped like that
shout out templates
whatever works
wow these are great good job you guys
yeah these are amazing spot on holy [ __ ]
I could see that I mean
this one is they're both like right
[ __ ] on dude yeah
holy [ __ ] mine I exaggerated a little
too much on the sharpening and stuff it
finds a little bit more of a parody of a
quartering thing yours is good I like it
because he does do that where he'll like
[ __ ] with the contrast heavily to make
people look crazy but I just like I
crank those knobs all the way to Max you
deep fried it by the way this picture of
Dan screaming is my fave
I feel good now
okay good job guys it's a whole uh
exploration of quartering yes good stuff
how long we've been going by the way uh
two hours and 40 minutes it's a short up
I actually have to leave so that I get
there in time what do you want to do for
dinner are you still hungry
what do you want to eat Mexican
you want to do you want to get barbecue
[Music]
eat the sour and barbecue she got a bad
Ranch and [ __ ] herself for like not
shares three days
it's from the ranch she thinks it was
bad rain I'm pretty sure I will not I
had to wrench in my life
I've been saying I can never give it up
you know it's funny the the place where
you got that from my opinion has the
best Ranch yeah in my opinion it's a
good place so I'll tell you we or that
all it takes is one bad one right we
ordered there three nights in a row
because it was so in a row but pretty
close really yeah it was back to back to
back okay
and then on the third time
on the third time I guess something we
ate was really bad and our stomach's got
super I'm sure that was the rain the
ranch my my whole body like I just know
it
I just know I can't even look at it
again yeah I got you I got you that's a
shame though ranch when it's good it
hits like nothing else man
telling you put that [ __ ] on the ribs
from that place oh man there's some
people saying what the hell is ranch uh
probably from other countries uh because
I think it really is an American thing
like what do you call Ranch in in Europe
Thousand Islands yeah but but the thing
is it's only salads dressing you don't
use it on any only use for solid no it's
insane to use it in any other content
okay
Ranch so much but you know what it's
funny that you say that ELO because it
was when I worked at the pizza place
yeah and people would ask for like four
sides of ranch and just [ __ ] drench
their pizza and it really
I I developed an aversion to it now I
think Ranch is disgusting after seeing
that I get that I get that a little
traumatic yeah time for you
all right so let's we have another main
topic here with Andrew Tay and it's
really fun it's not like super serious
it's just fun you guys are gonna enjoy
it actually doesn't involve me and it
involves Andrew Tate for this guy true
Geordie and it's it's very I think I'm
gonna dip out yeah I'm gonna go pee so
that we can uh keep going so I'll be
right back
and you're going to leave so I'll be
back in just a minute okay yeah
thanks for having me thanks for joining
thanks for coming
a little bonus elope for you all out
there
an H3 podcast how's your tummy doing Dan
Tommy's fine Tommy's fine tell me check
yep Frank like
I I still I feel a warmth kind of in my
gut but that's about all I'm feeling
right now I cannot believe you're
suffering in like so stoically I'm very
important the suffering's over the
suffering's over
um yeah I mean I still would never ever
do that again that was horrible it's
mostly about the [ __ ]
flavor flavor is horrible like the spice
the spice spice sucks you know it hurts
for a bit but it fades but that was one
of the most disgusting tasting things
I've ever put in my mouth like grounded
up pills yeah it's just industrial
that's why I said it like smelled like a
Home Depot aisle yeah for me the worst
part was my stomach afterwards I felt
like I got punched in my gut for like a
few hours yeah yeah
I have a pretty like
my stomach's pretty solid and I don't
get clearly from food it was weird for
me the worst part was um the screen cap
of me after that [ __ ] uh ruined my
life oh yeah that's right
well I I'm sure there's some of those
for me now from when I was sitting there
crying the whole subreddit is you but oh
really no no I haven't even looked yeah
I was trying to find something good for
socials it's not that bad honestly
really nothing oh boy I'm afraid to look
when we got here but even leaner who
went like the same amount of time nearly
um she was suffering after she wasn't
okay like you are now
yeah I hope I'm not speaking too soon
might get [ __ ] up a little bit later
I see there was this post list of
excuses Dan can use to avoid the hot
chip challenge do you people think so
little of me
all of my excuses were legit I only put
it off because the day that you all did
it I I was sick I was legitimately sick
and then all the other days it was like
we had like we had guests here it was
like
Ethan wants me to have it while we have
like an astrophysicist in the building
and it's like I'm not eating it today
um I mean in all honesty though you
could have eaten it on Monday and been
fine to pick up owie and everything too
now I know that I just wasn't sure how I
I didn't know I didn't know how badly it
was going to affect me but somebody in
chat said prime or Primal oh thank you
prep my nope Emoji
Primal I wanted to see if we could get
liver King to try the uh Hot Chip but I
don't know of course you want to do it I
ain't putting that [ __ ] in my body I
mean he'd be right to say that thank you
Derek runts for 20 bucks Eric shout out
to the crew shout out to you Derek Derek
is like a very loyal supporter of fine
love and Lena's house I'm sure okay I
was gonna say I thought I recognized
that name also Morgan says good morning
from Korea good morning Morgan Guten
Morgen Morgan Morgan
uh Dan you cannot keep this pod on the
rails
oh thank you for keeping this pod on the
rails I cannot spend another week
without the history famine crew
um
you're welcome
I guess we'll see what happens
I think we're fine you know what I mean
and I will say
I will give Jeremy
some serious credit here he is way less
of a whiny baby than a lot of people
like keemstar who definitely go and like
report like I I don't anticipate Jeremy
doing that he'll probably just make I
mean he'd probably thankful we talked
about him we give him we just gave him
juice for two more weeks I'm looking
forward to the thumb yeah exactly
exactly forward to those rare sweet
sweet centers yeah those little nice
two more weeks Dana that's like four
months worth of yeah it might be it
might be multiple videos a day he's
defended ELO before when ricegum was
talking [ __ ] he's not the worst he's not
the worst he genuinely isn't like he's
that's why I always say he's a buffoon
more than he's like evil he's just a low
IQ and bread loser which isn't the worst
what do you call them
yes you're right not not a buffoon an
oaf no this is endearing I feel like
that's why I said he's an elf because
there is there is some element of
there's something there there's
something there yeah yeah the one video
he made about ELO was taught had a
really funny title that was not ironic
it was like defending Queen Ela from
right right super wild yep and it was
not ironic
there it is
mm-hmm
all right let's move on to this Andrew
Tate thing and then
it's a rice gum attacks goddess Ela
Klein goddess
[Laughter]
and that's the thing I think he really
he there's a definitely an element of
hurt hurt fan
so I think he genuinely was a huge fan
at one point
and a lot of these guys were fans to an
extent but I think can we rebuild
Bridges with quarter not after today
that's even close to the worst [ __ ] I've
said about him yeah I mean oh my God a
little came out
uh let's let's let's uh
let's move on to the tape part but
here's the thumbnail it's actually crazy
thumbnail is pretty tame yeah what
happened he's changed when the
thumbnails changed he changed
he fell off
ricegum attacks a goddess Gila Klein
that's how we know that he doesn't make
his thumbnails because he made that
thumb this one's dog [ __ ] dude
anyway so Andrew Tate
recently announced just
like two weeks ago that he's converting
to Islam
okay and good for you faith is a
beautiful thing actually I'm what am I
saying I'm just trying to be I don't I'm
not a big fan of Faith but if that's
what it is then go for it it would be
straight I mean I think it could be good
if people are like don't it's like
anything you know use responsibly right
Andrew take converts to Islam prayer
video goes viral oh we have we have a
okay so he's getting all into it
Andrew Tate tweeted out or no he rumbled
out
our truth though looks like a truth
should I get on Truth this is why I'm
Muslim any Christian who believes in
good and understands the true battle
against evil must convert oh no is he
already going on
he's already like going fatwa on
Christians he's already come in he's
already proclaimed Jihad this is uh a
big L on our part I gotta say it's it's
very my aunt sent it to me first oh
really yeah she's religious and she goes
this is so [ __ ] embarrassing wait so
what are all the other all the other
people you know who are fans of him and
who are Islamic oh they're probably
gonna love it you think I'll fill you in
after I go home for break oh yeah I love
this any Christian who is good must
convert
so be patient indeed the promise of
Allah is truth this guy's already
quoting the Quran it's like chill bro
you've been in the religion for two
weeks let it simmer a little bit man
I feel like it's like an ad if this was
about anything else I would have assumed
he was paid to do it seems so
disingenuous join Islam Today
yeah like who who is paying him to do
this he says he's okay but he's
obviously in a lot of pain if you turn
into religion now like like let's be
honest if you're a non-religious person
usually it's something traumatic or a
lot of pain you're experiencing that
causes you to turn from being a secular
person to religion in general yeah no my
aunt that scared the [ __ ] out of me and
my cousins who's super religious she got
religious after she got a divorce yeah
yeah
so I think it's interesting because you
know the alpha male who says he's got it
he's like great this belies that in a
sense I think he's so I think Andrew's
suffering
and now he's ready to make the world
suffer if they don't convert
ible
[Music]
oh thank you so much
[Music]
United
I gotta say this is super religious by
the way to record this you think he
tagged Allah in the post or
foreign
it is true may Allah guide and accept
Andrew Tate the Harem police
is that serious it's posted by The Harem
police the Haram police have been trying
to give me for years wait who are they
no I'm just kidding okay but I every
everyone who's Muslim I feel like is out
on please
got it there's more
he's playing wood Tigers is that part of
Islam
no it's part of more being a Saudi well
yeah
there's a lot of debate I'm seeing
I'm singing on Tick Tock actually where
Muslims are like I've seen Shacks on on
um Shaq is like a priest for Islam where
they're on Tick Tock talking about how
people shouldn't be so dismissive
Muslims shouldn't be trying to push him
away or discourage him that as a Muslim
you should be accepting of anyone trying
to join the religion but personally I
kind of feel like listen that's true but
if you're two weeks in and you're
declaring war on Christians let's like
chill bro you know what I mean you're
taking it too far dude relax
you need to be in the religion at least
a year before you start committing a uh
jihuds is that right or no
uh I'm just sorry I'm just kidding he
would argue that he's he's not saying
he would say that uh it's nothing
against Christians but he's trying to
argue that they're too passive and if
you really want a religion that actually
that actually is strict then
Islam is the way to go right Jesus
Christ is too forgiving yeah yeah it's
this weird like we were talking about
with Hassan a little about how a lot of
Muslims in my hometown like Jordan
Peterson's like this weird crossover
between conservatives and Muslims uh
strange strange times
so uh the story continues
[Music]
um
true Geordie is a YouTuber and twitch
streamer I've heard His Name a lot what
kind of content does he make so I'm not
super familiar with true Geordie I know
he's like jacked he's like a huge dick
he's jacked he has a podcast that he
does
um like bettering yourself top like
Alpha manosphere stuff
okay
well apparently he has beef with with
Andrew
and uh he over the weekend
was accused by Andrew of making
islamophobic comments
here's the clip
let's just turn it up here
are you fighting Andrew
undertake got God on his side now
there's no way Brian would win that
um although I would gladly blow myself
over if I could take that [ __ ] [ __ ]
bag with us
um that's the use of a stereotype there
which is obviously not what he uh I'm
just saying if he really wants to prove
it
yeah this guy did such a down move
that's a stereotype he didn't mean that
wait we missed the we missed the
culmination here which is obviously not
what he uh I'm just saying if he really
wants to prove it do the right thing
actually somewhat sensitive I would say
with his friend there as being a kind of
kind of like sensitive to the issue
right so it's kind of impressive at
least that he associate with somebody
who's sensitive uh I don't know uh what
what's your thoughts a b so I don't have
to speak on this
um will
do we have defending entertain in the
title and Andrew no we're not defending
Andrew Dave just to be clear all right
that was a gag yeah I mean it is
I'm kind of used to it you know uh
growing up post 911 but yeah I think
sometimes people just toss things around
and not realize what they're saying uh
it is uh we we all aren't strapped with
a
with a b word I don't know if I'm
allowed to say that
well on this channel maybe not yeah I
mean it's just a tasteless joke yeah
very tasteless joke it's not it's the
that being said I've spoke to the uh the
Muslim Council and we do not accept uh
uh people in the chat are actually
saying uh the the guy that you said is
his Dan uh his is married to a Muslim
woman oh that is so amazing he's
actually sensitive about okay okay
that's interesting that's why I found
children are Muslim there you go oh my
goodness so he's really that's really
stepping into quite a bit interesting
interesting okay so um okay obviously
it's an offensive joke right yeah okay
it's fine you know it happens
um it's not the is it's not like the
worst thing you could say about uh man
no I mean it's definitely Prejudiced and
yeah playing off of bad stereotypes and
everything so yeah yeah it's not a great
thing to say but and he immediately got
called out on it by his co-host or
producer or whoever he is so anyway
Andrew Tate eats this up as a newly uh
converted uh
uh Muslim for two weeks
and he is going to war with Jordy over
this comment it's very
very
funny
wait this is his all I recognize this
face he posted this himself
true Jordi decided it was funny to
insult Muslims by insinuating they all
blow themselves up
to insult the religious beliefs of
billions of people worldwide you're
going to learn very quickly
that was a mistake
um
King what again what's so interesting to
me this has 50 000 likes 1.7 million
views
he has like conservative like manosphere
fans and now all of a sudden they hear
about Islam the sanctity of of his own
it's so weird oh conservatives have
always been staunch Defenders yeah yes
so woke I mean they're they really are
and this is a beautiful this is a new
page that we love he's really I'm a man
of God yeah he found his new weapon he's
going to use Islam as his excuse for
everything and this is the first of many
to come
use it it's going to make us look bad
each time right so here he is uh
here he is going to war
there's not many people in the world I
have a personal beef with
I've had some internet beefs back and
forth there's very few people I
personally dislike one of them is true
Geordie he always told me long enough
he's in Good Company my man we got to
get together
personally dislike one of them is true
Geordie anyone who's told me long enough
understands why he's a very insulting
fat vulgar oh he got him with the fat no
okay maybe not that woke
foreign
picture of him I thought he was looked
like a yeah
he calls him fat but that's like the the
best uh Alpha bro insult of course to
each other how you [ __ ] It's Gonna
Hurt let me see dude
hold on hold on True Jordy full body
shirtless
I just typed that [ __ ]
what this guy's fat this is him yeah
that's what I thought he's like super
jacked
okay if he's fat then I'm really in
trouble
[Music]
okay interesting insult he's a [ __ ]
he's an unlike he's a very insulting fat
vulgar he's a [ __ ] he's an unlikable
person he's not very smart he's stupid
he has his little girlfriend who sits
next to him and they did a video about
me long ago where they were insulting a
bunch of women who worked for me calling
them horrible names he made full-grown
women cry I replied and said that's a
horrible thing to do and he should
apologize he refused to apologize
because he was full of hate turns out
the man was full of hate because he
ended up begging for dildos off of a
woman the screenshots were leaked of him
begging for dildos begging to suck on
them begging to be cheated on because he
likes to be dominated by females he sits
there fat that's why he eats so much to
try and pretend he's bigger than he is
he sits there fat trying to convince the
world it's muscle and that he's a tough
guy but truthfully he begs to be
dominated by females dude he is so he is
so mentally ill he's so unless he's like
you've insulted an entire religion how
dare you and then in the same breath
insults 50 of the population of the
planet because he goes he goes but at
the same time I hate fat people gay
people uh uh women who are dominant men
who like to be submissive
there's nothing okay
sounds like he's got a fun he's having a
fun time at home Andrew you're the one
who's like I can't get off anymore
because I [ __ ] too many women my dick
doesn't work because I [ __ ] too many
women
I can [ __ ] a new girl every night but I
don't want to because it's boring now
suck a little bit of dick
so this person is genuinely a piece of
[ __ ] and now after me converting to
Islam he made a piece on one of his
podcasts saying that I'm not true in my
conversion and then insulted all Muslims
then the Muslims blow themselves up and
I should go blow myself up we should all
blow ourselves up making [ __ ] racist
comments it's just two weeks ago he
would have been totally down with that
joke
yeah you know it's just fun you've been
you've been a Muslim for two weeks bro I
hope he I hope he's not having any
premarital sex anymore if uh if he's so
right right
I hope the Hustler's University is all
about um
absolutely for sure
also a lot of people in our chat were
pointing out how funny it is that he
converts to Islam and all of a sudden
the cigar's gone and the hook is in
[Laughter]
um
when you sign up they give you a
standard issue well hold on talk talk
about racially stereotyping yourself
just because you're you're Muslim now
doesn't mean you need to smoke hookah
bro you can still smoke a cigar
like hello what are you gonna put on a
fez and [ __ ] like yeah he's gonna
wind up in a hookah lounge in Morocco oh
I was like dude come on now
an entire religion as if that's somehow
funny
let me tell you something my friend and
if true Jordi if you're watching this
this is a message directly to you uh-oh
there are certain times in life you need
to know when to shut the [ __ ] up there
are certain things which are not funny
certain things are not Beyond reprisal
you don't sit in insult a man's religion
just like you don't insult a man's
entire company and the people who work
for him that's one thing but to insult
my religion
making ignorant jokes about [ __ ]
blowing ourselves up thinking that's
going to go without consequence he's
like I'll teach you I'm gonna blow you
up
I'll teach you to make jokes like that I
mean listen he's threatening ourselves
up thinking that's going to go without
consequence You're Gonna Learn very
quickly my friend if that was a mistake
it's awesome
sounds like he's threatening violence on
him so it's like kind of great
a little ironic somebody says Abella
who's a one of our great patrons patrons
says Andrew Tate to Islam is Trisha is
to Judaism
that's an interesting analogy but
I think what Trisha does is even worse
actually because you can switch to you
can become his Muslim but the way that
Trisha will get you in prison no I'm
kidding Patricia was I don't know much
about converting to Islam is it like
that
uh it's easier to convert to Islam than
it is yeah it's faster they're
recruiters yeah more people yeah in
Judaism you have to like you have to
take an exam basically you have to study
you have to prove to the rabbi you're
committed right yeah and so what Trisha
did was super [ __ ] she's like I paid a
rabbi and he said I'm Jewish now it's
like no you didn't you [ __ ] liar but
anyway it's a good analogy Just give me
a reason to talk about Trisha but we
don't need to do that
stop it Bella don't get me started
yeah I'm done don't worry guys
people get so edgy when I talk or on
edge
so um that was pretty fun right I mean
two weeks in and he's already
threatening violence Ray is my
interpreting the end of that right oh
yeah totally yeah sounded like he was
threatening yeah
like that's like the the vision of what
people imagine when I think of like evil
Muslim villain in like Hollywood it's
like this like raid of his face the
crazy eyes like but that's that's funny
to me he's like yo Muslims aren't
violent which he's right right like on
that that's not true not inherently of
course that's a that's a terrible
stereotype yeah but then he follows It
Up by and I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you for
saying that right
and again like so offended that somebody
would say something offensive about a
religion which obviously you shouldn't
but then in the same breath and just
like you're fat you listen to women your
pathetic beta like
he should move to Iran or Saudi Arabia
and just get really into it I think
he'll be in
UAE or something like that that's more
history in Dubai yeah I have a couple
slaves right we love that
um we have more let's see Tate's
response oh true wait an apology video
by true Geordie did he really apologize
he did oh [ __ ] people must have got
angry at him for that one eh yeah his
apology went up pretty shortly after
that video of Andrew
God oh my goodness
so is true Geordie a sensitive King I
don't know anything about him dude he
tears up he does specifically his uh his
uh co-host probably hit him hard he said
right yeah he has a direct uh connection
within his uh podcast right you'll see
he isn't necessarily crying about Andrew
Tate they kind of go off on a tangent
but it's connected I time stamped it the
comments were kind of vile this man
isn't sorry he's just trying to save his
career
since when do Manos fear people care
about the sanctity of Islam I'm so
confused about this whole thing and also
they're just they're so ready to cancel
somebody I thought cancel culture was
like the worst plague it's just it's the
hypocrisy of it all what he said is
offensive but like these these are the
people that claim nothing gets to them
and cancel cultures so terrible or
whatever and of course it's all [ __ ]
and and these have a ton of of votes too
this man this is an apology this man's
name is a reality check 5 000 likes
what
so weird because I thought cancel
culture didn't exist in this world at
all
comedy's back on Twitter anyway let's
hear what he has to say I made a joke in
questioning the Newfound faith of his
that conveniently comes at a time when
he needs as many supporters as he can
get it was a stupid joke as much as I
don't want yo I'm sorry but I just I
always got a comment when I see the
biggest [ __ ] table I've ever seen it
looks like they're talking right to each
other but then
look at this look at this [ __ ] the size
of this I love that thing
wait it is yeah yeah what is going on
they're using the same table Yeah they
use Highway set too they because this is
in Howies
huh no no I'm saying impulsive they they
go around they used uh how he said oh
they use yeah oh I see it yeah I see I
think that table's sick just for the
record it's too big I want a table that
big it would be it would be great for
the show it's they're basically sitting
in other rooms How You Gonna even
connect at that point like you won't
even hear it it's better for the camera
we are very limited on our camera angles
with our table that's what I've been
advocating for I don't think I'd be
comfortable sitting that far away like
genuinely it's too far away
okay well maybe there's a middle ground
we can find it it looks kind of like
Game of Thrones yeah that's what I was
thinking yeah back then they had tables
that long so that the the people you're
sitting with couldn't lunge at you with
the dagger
anyway
as much as I don't want to repeat the
joke I think it's only right so that
people have contacts who don't
understand uh I said if he really wants
to prove he's a Muslim he should blow
himself up as a suicide bomber or
something like that actually no you said
which I thought was the best part he
should do the right thing
and blow himself up
but that's I
okay okay get it together when I when I
say that out loud when I'm when I'm
aware of it
[ __ ] horrendous you know it was one
of those off the cuff remarks that uh I
made in a with a total lack of thought
dude he's being canceled by the
manosphere like he is on the apology
tour yeah he is being pressured they're
saying this is literally the same
comment you'd see on like a James
Charles cancellation I know it's
indistinguishable from yeah exactly it's
exactly awesome it's so awesome
his podcast and his content to my
understanding is more Sports based but
of course the crossover between yeah
complete manosphere and sports is pretty
high yeah there's like a lot of yeah
football and boxing mainly yeah I have
seen some comments saying that I guess
are familiar with him saying he's not a
manosphere but can I
like I I think the joke warrants an
apology that's fine but like
it seems just like I don't know they're
coming down so [ __ ] hard oh someone's
saying H3 they're not manosphere okay
maybe not I don't know I don't know
someone says Ethan watched jordy's video
on Logan Paul when he went to the forest
I think he'd be pleasantly surprised by
him okay cool yeah I think I like him so
far I mean he seems like
like
somebody said his co-host is a lefty wow
I love that see I like that
okay
Jordy true Jordy
yeah he had an Ethan moment there
someone said
it's not that you didn't get banned so
you know what I mean not yet anyway
well that's another thing I mean
I'm not saying I agree with it but yeah
he's getting a lot of [ __ ] he's talking
about another culture I mean you've got
a bunch of [ __ ] for saying something
about someone who's you know also Jewish
so I can imagine that he was a
bra I didn't say [ __ ] wrong not let's
not I I was I was debating
bringing that up
let's just move past it yeah yeah that
would be the best thing to do we have
one strike already let's just yeah I'm
sorry I was trying to get a vacation
basically I'm just saying with the
holidays coming up Ben Shapiro's no stop
to come
to
each other
enjoy my homemade homemade a lot because
this holiday that's very sweet that's
very sweet yeah we make our own home
vodkas which is a Jewish tradition yes
he'd have a lot of fun you just use the
the what was the brand that you beat
your mom with yes I've never used the
manischevitz
I forgot about that that was awesome
oh Jordan Peterson just on the podcast
okay I mean I don't know I have to watch
it
Ethan has said worse people oh yeah
definitely that my thing was like I mean
it's definitely worn an apology and
that's good I think it's nice to
apologize but yeah it seems like
not that [ __ ] big that [ __ ] bad
well and it's sorry it's just not and
it's also it's just a bad joke and I do
that [ __ ] all the time and you apologize
and it's it's the level of bad faith of
the criticism because
of all the things that we've enumerated
here I mean he's been Muslim for 48
hours he thinks he's against cancer
culture but he's ready to cancel this
guy in a heartbeat he's ready to kill
him and he's so against stereotyping and
all this stuff but this is the guy that
says that women are less than men in
every regard he says that without a
second thought so it's just you know the
hypocrisy is
it's a lot it's a lot yeah and doesn't
come back to bite Tate in the ass too
because uh the harnam police don't sleep
man right
[Laughter]
but also every time it's about Tate you
got to be mindful that he has his like
Discord Army type thing that just pushes
that's true so I I don't even think most
of those people are angry is you think I
don't know that's an interesting yo you
think he's on Discord being like yo
y'all this dude is not Haram yeah that's
what I was just laughing at imagine he
converts like a bunch of his kid
audience to Islam
I mean hey I mean he's trying right yeah
religion it is a good deed I mean like
it's just such a [ __ ] weird situation
I'm interested in this new Evolution
like I wonder where it's going to take
him because you like you said he's got
this Hustler University he's like a
pickup artist right like where how does
this hit in with like fundamental Islam
right he went he's like it seems like
he's pretty hardcore now he didn't get
into like the set like the really mild
version he's like in the Deep End right
yeah
let's see if he fast this year for
Ramadan yeah exactly dude he's gonna
have to he's gonna lose some muscle mass
mm-hmm
there it is
thank you everybody for uh watching that
with us did he apologize and then oh no
true Jordi gots dropped by his sponsors
yeah and he's
a Easter video
It's gotta be like you said it's got to
be his Discord freaks that just bombard
everybody yeah there's just no it's just
I'm like this is so annoying I mean it's
the same thing that it was not a good
thing to say right and he did it and he
he should apologize but I'm just saying
like in terms of all the worst things in
the world you can say if you're a
comedian it's like sometimes you say you
put your foot in your mouth and you
apologize and you move on but like this
whole thing seems to be so blown up out
of proportion I mean that's just I don't
know gym shark we do not condone racism
discrimination islamophobia of any form
we do not agree with the comments made
by Brian AKA true Geordie and have
suspended our relationship with him and
definitely effective immediately I mean
it's not like he was on a soapbox
talking about how we need to like yeah
yeah round up the yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah thank you I'm just saying like
I don't know just
by the way it happened to us many times
like you say something like that you're
gonna wind up losing sponsors especially
if
people uh you know
start Mass emailing them or whatever
which like you said I'm sure he had his
little Discord go and do and these the
people that mass emailed they're not
even customers of course not they're not
we're gonna buy [ __ ]
you know here's the top comment it's a
top G never loses so yeah it's just do
not want to get canceled That's crazy
dude ugh it's gross
I'm just curious to see how he's gonna
look try to look cool after this Tate if
he's like this devout Muslim now it's
just that compilation of top G can't do
that no more in the comment right there
let's see is this the same one we saw is
it all Muslims then the Muslims blow
themselves up and I should should we
just sound like that
Muslims blow themselves up no no just
kidding it's a joke don't don't kill me
Jim shark oh yeah Ethan well
You're Gonna Learn for that joke you're
gonna learn lessons oh yeah you're gonna
learn the hard way never to [ __ ] with uh
never to make jokes kiddo I don't know I
maybe maybe I'm not being sensitive
enough but I just I don't know this
whole thing is kind of shocking as a
Muslim I think it's ridiculous
like
it's good that he apologized and he can
not make those kind of jokes anymore but
this whole thing is
it's 100 manufactured by his fans yeah
and then you know the gym shark they
took the [ __ ] bait and it sucks I
guess not he's just having a big joke
out of it I mean like if you're talking
about um
cancer culture how you hate it this is
basically like perpetuating this [ __ ] so
bad like damn you can't even say
I don't know whatever bro they're the
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is annoying
there it is
interesting true Geordie is uh canceled
we hate true Geordie
we hate him folks
um uh
true Jordy uh money
money maybe Tate's the new try guy he's
trying Islam
yeah I filled the spot
let's see is he active on YouTube now or
he does like a podcast is that what he
does
I'm just loving
because this was him integrating himself
into that room
so this is um
his last video he had deji on and then
Jordan Peterson was a month ago it
actually didn't get that many views
compared to his other ones I did okay
but that's interesting that you'd think
whenever Jordan goes on a show like this
he gets like a gajillion views
what's the definition of
definition
is trying to elevate yourself up the
status hierarchy and if you don't know
that you're just ignorant and if you're
and and blind and you're even more
dangerous than you would be if you were
conscious of your true motivations and
so it's all about power now that's just
not true it's not all about power are
you following love I heard you laughing
no it's so funny because
yeah it doesn't make sense at all and I
know if we knew the context it wouldn't
have made more sense it doesn't matter
by the way I've been taking Jordan's
advice and I got a SUNY pen pal and that
shit's not working
I sent him a letter and he's like who
the [ __ ] are you this is weird so Jordan
Peterson your uh your advice for Muslims
take a pen pal
write some letters
we need to bridge The Divide
power and in fact if you try to govern
your relationships based on power your
true relationships you will fail so
imagine that you you your wife let's say
whatever
how is people it's like he drones on and
on and all about the same [ __ ]
Bella Simmons thank you for the gift did
F the top G I appreciate the wife man
yeah
wait someone said bobert is 62 votes
behind are you serious oh is it that
close pull that up if you have an update
62 votes
can I say something hi these elections
recently have been so close that it
it doesn't make sense how can you have
millions of people casting a vote and
then these elections are regularly
coming down to 49.49 well this one is a
it's a local election so it's not it's
not but but a lot of the state elections
even the uh presidentials they end up
being like one percent margins it just
seems kind of insane here's where we're
at
wow
with over 95 percent of the votes in
yeah it's going to be extremely close
dude how is that possible
I don't know possible I don't know it's
probably like a feedback loop they look
at the polls beforehand and whoever's
down spend more on marketing and they
kind of just equal out sure they see you
they can't remember the voters are more
motivated to get out because of that but
yeah that's interesting
I guess we'll find out
it'll probably be decided by leftovers
tomorrow morning so oh yeah we'll either
be celebrated please let her lose
this isn't a runoff thing this is winner
take all this is
Do or Die oh my God
50 [ __ ] votes that
that's too close
like ever since George Bush hanging
Chads I feel like election's been like
like constantly almost impossibly close
[Music]
it's a no I mean it happens but like I
mean Biden and Trump wasn't close
no he got destroyed yeah even Hillary
destroyed him too technically popular
vote right
all right how long we've been going
because we've been going for three hours
and 20 minutes the only thing left is
the Taylor Swift drama that everyone's
been wanting to hear my take on this but
it's kind of old news at this point but
yeah just watch it real fast and see
okay let me watch it so I can get
claimed real fast
oh well then I don't know
would love to hear Ethan's thoughts on
the whole Taylor Swift fat shaming
debate when the Pod comes back so okay
um Olivia you probably know the context
but so she does this music video she
gets on the scale she stares at the
scale it says fat right well is that it
the song is called anti-hero so
essentially when she does that she is
labeling the word fat as being anti-hero
but the director you'll see I put an
album of people defending it too so this
uh this uh her Twitter Handle by the way
is fat Fab feminist
as an actual fat person genuinely how
are we she's an actual fat person the
genuine thing baby
I'd like to know at what point you
become a genuine fat person like where's
that where's that threshold am I a
genuine fat person or am I uh an
imposter fat person
you're in a reform
she's like trust me she's like trust me
when you see me you'll know
well I'm a genuine thing
as an actual fat person genuinely how
are we supposed to feel seeing this
watching a thin person remind the whole
world that one of their biggest fears is
being fat is looking like me demonizing
the word fat while never having the
experience of living in a fat body fat
phobic so I do have to give a disclaimer
Taylor Swift has previously spoken about
her struggles with eating disorders
specifically she had like a Netflix
documentary where she really talked
about it so it's it's not it's not like
she has never expressed
foreign
difficulty with this with this topic I
think everybody's entitled to feel like
she's not it's it's stupid how who are
you to say this whole thing of genuinely
fat it's like you're gate keeping fat I
mean everybody sees their bodies
differently and by the way I don't think
this is fat phobic and the slightest bit
fat phobic is like
not to prop myself up as like the real
genuine fatty here but um fat phobic in
my opinion is the [ __ ] that like fat man
bad stuff where it's like he's fat and
therefore his opinion's invalid like
people literally see you uh as less than
it's the first time I actually felt fat
phobia personally
um and the way that I really feel it is
when people are like I'm don't take you
seriously because you're fat this is not
that this is just her expressing her own
experience with her own body like you
could don't own the word fat it's not
fat phobic I don't know I find this
whole thing a little bit exhausting
because it just it's just
it's just like
the whole perspective the way she's
written it's like a thin person is
reminding me that one of the biggest
fears in the world is being fat what do
you mean reminding you like nobody wants
to be fat I'll just be real I'm fat
nobody wants to be fat are we pretending
like that's not the case it's not
healthy and nobody wants to be fat
everybody wants to be a healthy size and
and being fat if a fat is not healthy
I'm like that's just the [ __ ] fact of
it not everyone's young and healthy
and uh you know it's like
we're not you can't ask the whole world
to tiptone around your insecurity she
goes when I see Taylor Swift's call
herself fat it reminds me that I'm a
that I'm fat and everybody hates me it's
like well that's your problem yeah you
got to address that [ __ ] it's not Taylor
Swift's problem the [ __ ] tiptoe
around you I also think the intention
was
it was it was clearly Taylor Swift's
critique on
that being so pertinent in in young
girls Minds like that the director says
that they use that word because it was
the most disgusting thing they could
think of so it's not it it it adds to
the story that she's trying to tell it's
not like it comes out of nowhere and
that's her actual ideology and that's
what she's preaching to her fans dude
even if it was I just don't think it's
but yeah I hear you it's giving Matt
it's giving yogurt store Vibes for sure
it's like dude they're not the whole
world can't cater around your
insecurities you gotta take
responsibility for some [ __ ] in your
life and I'm not saying that you know if
you're fat or overweight you're less
than I'm just saying if you're insecure
about it you gotta work on yourself and
not cater to the every get mad when
everyone else is just like minding their
own [ __ ] business and and then like
it's crazy I don't know it's just it's
not it's not genuine I feel like this
whole thing is
and I'm a genuinely fat person so I have
credentials here yeah another good
example of someone being fat phobic is
like when you call though Andrew Tafe
for supposedly like you know having
people locked up in the basement or
whatever and he's like oh yeah well
you're fat you know yeah yeah like he he
actually puts that in like as a
personality defect yeah and that's fat
phobic that is but but um this is more
her commenting on like her perception of
her body is I don't know I just I don't
see it this isn't her saying she's a bad
person because she's fat she's just
saying she feels fat and Everyone's
entitled to that emotion
uh you know you don't get the gate keep
feeling fat because you're genuinely fat
the whole thing is weird with the
genuinely fat thing too it's like you
want to own this
you want to own being genuinely fat you
know it's not that cool I I just think
it's not a it's not that cool of a club
to be in
the genuinely fat club is like it's just
not that [ __ ] it's just not that
[ __ ] cool of a club
just saying also people are upset with
her because they're saying she can't
really relate to someone who's actually
fat but at the same time we don't know
what her experience is like with having
cameras on you all the time and I'm sure
she's been called overweight several
times it's like a totally different
experience oh yeah it's like a woman
celebrity yeah I'm sure she's had all
kinds of you know sane scrutiny people
and photographers or agents or managers
uh Executives at the record label or
whatever like you gotta trim up before
the next tour oh yeah dude can you
imagine and and
um yeah she said she has her eating
disorder she's entitled to feel however
the [ __ ] she wants and she doesn't need
you gatekeeping being fat like that's
crazy dude I don't know let's keep going
because there's more apparently the
music video of the song anti-hero
depicts Taylor sipping on a scale oh we
saw this
the scales and that tweet if it it has
received criticism from fans who say
she's promoting fat phobia it's the same
tweet or there's more
and Taylor Swift fat discourse is
killing me people saying it's not
harmful or [ __ ] stupid just rotted
if my poor fat 13 year old self had sat
down and watched a skinny blonde woman
stand on the scale and say fat I would
have cried if she's fat what a Hope was
there for me well
I mean uh yeah listen listen
you got to deal with this I'm not she
this this tweet's [ __ ] up because now
I'm having a discourse with this
hypothetical 13 year old uh you got
you've got it right you can't control
what everyone you can't control the
world it's just not realistic and it's
not fair you can't control the world and
I feel like there is a way to put a
positive spin on seeing that too even as
you know a young girl if she saw the
video like
isn't it somewhat comforting seeing that
somebody that you look up to is
experiencing these same kind of
struggles like if you
uh are struggling with body image stuff
like that and then you are looking at
Taylor Swift and like oh I wish I looked
like her she's so skinny or whatever but
then you find out that oh she actually
has you know
eating disorder issues that she's
struggling with as well I don't know to
me
oh I can empathize with that person I've
known a lot of really healthy
sized or skinny even women in my life
who thought and felt they were fat
so this is a phenomenon
that happens that is you know causing a
lot of of pain to to women and and yeah
she's reaching out to them and their
experience is not less genuine than
yours sorry it's just not
Taylor Swift's music video where she
looks at the scale where it says fat
42 000 oh my God so this actually has
some movement it's a shitty way to
describe her body image struggles fat
people don't need to have it reiterated
yet again and it's everyone's worst
nightmare to look like us
dude she wasn't in a fat suit she was
I'm sorry this discourse is [ __ ]
insane to me it's impossible to
appreciate Taylor Swift and midnight as
an artist and call her out for blatant
fat phobia it's like you gotta reserve
your this criticism a little bit blatant
fat phobia like give her a [ __ ] break
that it's like dude
There's real fat phobia and I'm sorry
but like you can say this was a little
insensitive but the way they come for
her is just [ __ ] outrageous and she
clearly
Taylor Swift should have done better
because even if it's a relatable and an
intrusive thought is damaging and fat
phobic
bro I'm sorry but here I'm sorry but
this is [ __ ] insane it's insane
I'm not going to agree with this [ __ ]
it's just it's just insane and I'm a fat
person so I have credentials
uh funeral Queen donated 10 thank you
she said I don't think it's fat phobia
but I think you can't tell if someone is
healthy or not based on their size
some bodies are just bigger bodies are
neutral is the aim I think that's true
to an extent right I mean clearly at a
certain size
they're not healthy I mean at this size
where you're obese you're not out there
I mean what are we talking about
but yeah some people are big true Jordi
for example
massive dude
not fat or I don't know anything about
them but just saying am I correct like
like if you're obese you're not healthy
I mean I mean there are drawbacks to
that but I think that there is some
Nuance there and remember we were just
talking about somebody on the show
recently
uh who was on the bigger size and
everybody was pointing out how insanely
oh oh it was lizzo
remember when we were talking about
lizzo and the the whole like flute thing
or whatever and how she's like
unbelievably athletic and does like
crazy [ __ ] at her concerts and is
running around for like three hours
straight okay and um you know
but but which I'm just saying she's on
the bigger side but I think that she is
probably it's not she's not unathletic
or talented or something but I'm just
saying lizzo is obese and I'm and she's
and it's not healthy to be OBS like
that's just [ __ ] straight up I'm
sorry yeah okay it's just not I mean
there's study after study after study
after study
that being obese is one of the
yeah it's a big factor in heart disease
it's going to give you cancer it's going
to be heart disease it's going to lower
your life expectancy I'm sorry to say
this guys I don't know when this turned
into a sensitive thing but being like
obese or morbidly obese is the quickest
way to shave years off your life it just
is now I'm not saying that she's not
athletic I mean she is she's incredible
what she does right she's got a lot of
energy and stuff but
I don't know what to tell you guys it's
not healthy being fat you got to stop
lying to yourself about that
I'm sorry just not
Ethan's truly become skinning out now
I'm a skinny hitting
skinny person I don't have to tell you
guys like how are you gonna disagree
with me
it's it's it's just the truth
I I yeah no I'm not my skin by the way I
weigh 230 I'm still fat as [ __ ] bro
trust me I know I know I'm telling you
it's just like how is this a bad take
it's literally science
read the meta-analysis if you're
morbidly obese you're not you're gonna
[ __ ] die when's the last time you saw
eight-year-old more released person
when's the last time you saw an 80 year
old morbidly obese person you never do
because don't live that [ __ ] long
every 30 year old is like skinny uh
healthy you know what I'm saying like
all of them I'm just being real bro find
me one picture of an eight-year-old
morbidly obese person find me one find
me Dan I see you type in find me one
you're asking I'm sorry you guys you
guys start [ __ ] putting your head in
the ground I'm not saying it's wrong to
be fat you can be fat you can be even
happily fat you can be happily uh
overweight you could be happily uh
morbidly obese and not and you're
comfortable in your body and I think
it's wrong that people make you feel
less than than that but you but the
truth is you're not living a healthy
lifestyle and that and that that's your
choice I'm not I'm not like
I'm not trying to um to like judge you
for it I'm just saying that it is
unhealthy
like obviously come on like like people
that smoke or drink are not going to be
like bro don't say it's not unhealth
don't say it's unhealthy to smoke or
drink it's like it's fine that's your
that's your prerogative bro
it's not I'm sorry this is [ __ ]
insane I can't believe what I'm reading
in the chat
guys I don't even know how to fact check
I don't even you know I mean like this
it's so okay what am I going to send him
a fact about how it leads to a bunch of
different diseases that you know are
life-threatening like I don't I it would
be I felt ridiculous even trying to send
something it's common sense like if
you're not if you're not healthy you're
not healthy you know what I mean like
it's
I'm not in good shape I'm eating [ __ ] I
shouldn't be eating but
I don't know this is uh it's strange
seeing chat right now dude I'm sorry I'm
not gonna [ __ ] I I'm just saying
you're wrong Dan are you trying to find
me an 80 year old fat person I have been
looking I I'm looking they're not out
there
there's no fat eight-year-olds guys
there's no fat I mean of course there
are but you I know a picture okay you
can't you've already been looking I hear
you typing I was looking for somebody
that was like for a minute bro I was
looking for somebody that was like
yeah four or five hundred pounds you
know what I mean and I think you're
probably right about that
sure overweight elderly people I'm not
judging you guys if you're overweight
like me I'm obese probably technically
right
um
it doesn't make you a bad person right
it's just it's just something that you
know
you got to deal with everybody's got
different [ __ ] sorry
but it's not healthy to convince
yourself that it's not unhealthy okay
you got to be real about it
it's fine if you want to die at 60 and
you're fine with that I'm not even
joking if you are okay having a heart
attack at 50 or 60 years old 60 is
probably generous if you're overweight
probably 50
but you really [ __ ] like Big Macs
then then live your [ __ ] life bro
that's it
I can't believe what I'm reading here
guys
we have to be reality based we can't be
like Trump we can't be like Trump people
who like live in a fantasy world where
every whatever they want to believe is
true we got to live in the real world
Hill People
there's nothing wrong with being fat
okay we love we love our fatties
we love fatties bro we need a fatty
Union
where we can get coupons for McDonald's
and shoot
just like share all the tips for getting
the best calories per dollar
gonna stock up
now that there's advantages of being fat
right like if you get sick
or overweight probably you got you have
more weight it actually turns out that
old people who are slightly overweight
have a much better uh life expectancy
than all the people who are skinny
because they ten if they get sick or
something they tend to have a better
Outlook because they have Reserve energy
so here's a good thing here's a good way
to think about it
um
you know in a nature setting we're
dominant us fatties we put on the weight
and we're lasting through winter
[ __ ] we hibrating and all the
skinny [ __ ] are just they're just gonna
die okay we got that we got that
survival [ __ ]
yeah flashbacks what in a nature setting
yeah I know I know I had a flashback too
I know I shouldn't say that yeah
uh thank you Bella for the Dono she said
regardless of skinny people can be
unhealthy skinny people can be unhealthy
yeah of course I didn't healthy dude
skinny people can definitely be
unhealthy that's not like of course bro
skinny does not mean healthy that is for
sure
doesn't take away that being obese is
still also unhealthy if you're obese you
are still entitled to feel comfortable
in your own body yes
I sure as hell do she says get real guys
yes the 100 percent
you know
that's it
okay
I don't think I had a hard time the rest
of the weekend
that's it and I don't think you need to
be skinny to be happy or less fat you
know [ __ ] that's it
uh so her uh truth says as a morbidly
obese person the problem is so many
people use unhealthy to mask their
discomfort or fat phobia like we've been
told by every doctor
I agree with you but my problem
is like people who are going on the
offensive like you like I agree
as a fat person you don't need everybody
telling you you're fat and to lose
weight right like you you already you've
heard that a lot and at a certain time
it's like yeah [ __ ] leave me alone
but my problem is when people go on the
offensive
uh like they're doing the Taylor Swift
or me right now where they're like you
can't save being morbidly obese is
unhealthy
uh now
foreign
bird says skinny does not equal healthy
fat does not equal unhealthy that's true
but to an extent right like fat like how
fat are we talking you know what I mean
so morbidly obese
I feel like so um being unhealthy and
fat and skinny is so subjective maybe
like if you were to say like
statistically if you're bigger you have
a shorter life uh span or uh what's it
called I'm saying morbidly obese that's
a very specific categorization yeah of
bi of of BMI body whatever it is body
mass index
body fat index yeah like to be
classified as morbidly abuse
that's pretty high on the
on the scale here
look at this helpful look at this
helpful chart you guys
you gotta open this helpful chart what's
your BMI normal
overweight
obese morbidly obese red see it's red
guys so you know it's bad
green I'm kidding
all right let's wrap it up
please
thank you
like here actually this is a chart that
like [ __ ]
uh I'm five eleven
so it's kind of crazy when you look at
this my normal weight or wait I'm 37
right guys
uh 42.
wait what is this oh my weight yeah my
way so I'm actually was like at 350.
so I guess I was obese I wasn't I was
like halfway through obese
so my 350. no no yeah like my normal to
get in the normal range it's 165 I
haven't weighed that much in like
that seems like really low it's kind of
crazy people are gonna hate that you're
looking at this shark why
um just when doctors use this in every
[ __ ] office in the across the entire
Globe but the chat says that BMI is
flawed so okay it does not count for
different body other types I suppose
you guys bro I'm not even gonna [ __ ]
play this game with you guys stop it
dude the chat
I'm seriously not gonna play this game
with you guys I'm not saying This is
Gospel it's interesting to look at
I mean I agree that's kind of crazy 165.
that's like really really skinny for me
so that doesn't seem like that seems
like too skinny that is wild like I
think my ideal weight is like 180 and
that says technically it's overweight
it's kind of weird
but obviously these are General
these are just general guides obviously
it's not uh
mathematic it's just like a general
thing
but I know what to say dude you Fatty's
got to be real about this [ __ ] bro I'm
[ __ ] over trying to it's just crazy
one of my crazy world it's a crazy world
bro stop it
you can't live in your own reality leave
me the [ __ ] alone dude if you're if
you're sensitive about being fat you got
to deal with your own [ __ ] don't yell at
me go see a therapist bro I don't know
what to sell you the whole world can't
be sensitive because if you have an
insecurity stop
foreign
been going for almost four hours now
really all right let's wrap it up thank
you guys nice to have a such a nice
wonderful ending here
um I don't know what's going on here I'm
living in Crazy World apparently I love
fat people bro they're my fave I'm not
saying you're a bad person for being fat
okay stop please we're still friends
don't unsubscribe and stop please remain
a member okay right Dan right thank you
beers with friends all right thank you
guys love y'all see you tomorrow morning
for a great episode of leftovers we got
all kinds of tea to sip tomorrow and uh
see you guys then please don't hate me
we're just having fun here
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]